online workers get their pay cut
people are angry that so many of the
cracks exposed by this pandemic still
have no solution
like in long-term care
or in indigenous communities where the
lack of decent housing and clean
drinking water mean that the pandemic
has hit them harder
people are angry and scared that the
climate crisis is threatening their
homes
and livelihoods with more extreme
weather
like floods and fires
so we need to have a plan to respond to
that
and we need to work together to deal
with the issues facing canadians
we were sent here just six months ago
elected in the minority government to
get to work for people we need to meet
the real anger and frustration that
people are experiencing right now with a
clear vision about how to make life
better
this starts by addressing the things
that have clearly gotten worse in this
pandemic
like finding a place to call home
it is simply impossible for so many
canadians to be able to find a roof over
their heads to find a home that's in
their budget that has to be fixed
life is getting harder people can't
afford their groceries they can't pay
the bills but it's not getting harder
for everyone
the rich and powerful have gotten
more
rich and powerful
throughout this pandemic we've seen
their wealth increase
so we need to restore the promise of
canadians that we can all share in a
good future
canadian sent us here not even six
months ago to work for them to deliver
the solutions they need
we are committed to that and we need to
be committed to getting us through the
pandemic and rebuilding this country in
a way that is good for everyone
that is what we have to do now and that
is all of us in this house
uh
uh
foreign
interventions
exactly
is
prices the cost of living we have to
solve these problems thank you
questions and comments uh the honorable
member for uh kingston and the islands
thank you very much uh mr speaker i
listened uh quite intently to the uh
leader of the ndp and his uh discussion
on this debate and i thank him for
initiating this uh debate tonight i
heard him talk uh about uh um uh you
know the actions that have been going on
outside and how he condemns the the
behavior and i would agree with him that
uh there certainly is a lot that's been
happening it's a lot it's more than just
a few bad apples as he rightfully
pointed out we're seeing instance after
instance this is not about one or two uh
bad apples here or there but my question
to him has to do with the fact that he
indicated that he was pleased to see
that a number uh that the three
different levels of government were
coming together
where does he see that discussion
happening what what suggestions does he
have for that group certainly he
wouldn't suggest that they negotiate
with what's going on given his previous
comments what does he recommend uh to be
some possible solutions that those three
levels of government should be
discussing
honourable member for burnaby south
well the four things that i've outlined
i think that what we need to see
is that the federal government stop
looking for excuses and show leadership
and say we are here to help we're going
to do everything possible to help and
we're not going to hide behind excuses
we're going to be proactive and look for
solutions
we also need to see that there is a
clear plan to get us out of this
pandemic there are significant problems
that we've been up against for the past
two years and we need to see some real
solutions our health care system cannot
be in a position where it is at the
brink of collapse every time there's an
additional wave of kobe 19 so we need
sustainable long-term funding increase
the funding for our for our health care
system and we need to solve those
problems we also need to make sure that
the money that is funding this this uh
occupation is stopped we know that
there's a significant amount of foreign
funding particularly from the states uh
that has to stop and finally there are a
lot of frustrations that people feel in
general canadians have been angry for a
while now because they've done
everything they can to get through this
pandemic but things have gotten worse
it's harder to own a home it's harder to
pay the bills we need to work together
in this house to provide solutions to
those problems to give people hope
as an answer to the hate that we see
rising we need to give people hope as a
way forward
julie come out to our questions and
comments the owner of honorable member
for kildonan st paul
the honorable leader of the ndp for his
remarks uh mr speaker i have to say i do
believe the ndp leader should be a
compassionate man i do believe that the
ndp with vigilance fights for the
marginalized so that's why i'm just a
bit surprised i like his comments on the
he must be hearing them his party must
be hearing the damage that's been done
to children to seniors in isolation job
losses i mean the ndp is traditionally
the party of standing up for for workers
we've seen workers lose their jobs
because of their personal health choices
we've seen
significant damage done to children done
to teenagers and to the mental health of
the nation alcohol and drug dependency
has gone up we can go on and on and on
about the impacts that canadians have
felt as a result of government actions
to address the pandemic and i think that
outside what's happening
is a result of that trauma that
canadians have experienced so i would
just like his comments on that really i
would like to hear some compassion for
the eruption of trauma that we're we're
seeing outside and across the country
burn it be south
i want to be clear who i stand with i
stand with the healthcare workers and i
compassionate to the people that have
given so much to us and i denounce the
fact that they are been made to be
afraid to walk down the streets i
compassionate to the families of people
in ottawa who are wanting to send their
kids to school that have been kept all
night by people who want to overthrow
the government
i'm compassionate to workers in downtown
core who've been harassed and
intimidated by these members of the
convoy i'm compassionate to young people
who've been harassed
and verbally assaulted by this i'm
compassionate to racialize people we see
symbols of hate i'm compassionate jewish
people who saw swastikas and nazi flags
flying i'm compassionate to racialize
people and black people who saw
confederate flags and say how is this
happening in our country
that's who we're standing with
we're standing with the people we're
saying this is not canada this is not
what we represent this hate
the desecration of war memorials the
vandalizing of the terry fox moral this
is not canada this is not who we stand
for and i want to stand with people who
are saying this is wrong i want to stand
with the truckers who are saying
this convoy doesn't represent us we're
worried about our wages being lost are
we worried about wage steps we're
worried about work conditions 90 of us
are vaccinated we don't care about what
this convoy is talking about they don't
represent our
concerns i'm standing with those people
i'm standing with the workers i'm
standing with families i'm standing with
health care workers i'm standing with
people that have been terrorized by this
convoy and i'm saying to them i'm going
to fight for you i'm going to stand up
for you and i understand that people in
canada are frustrated and we have to
respond to that frustration with a real
plan to get us through the pandemic with
real hope to deal with the problems that
people are faced with and we can do it
in comments
thank you mr speaker i'd like to thank
my colleague for his speech
and for the motions that he brought
forward for this debate
it's about time that we need to discuss
this elephant
and when i talk to my liberal colleagues
about
what their responsibility should be in
this situation
it's not really a national issue it's
not
a federal issue it happens at ottawa
it's happening in ottawa so it should be
the ottawa police who look after them
so they talk about it jurisdictions
i have a lot of trouble understanding
a share of responsibility and all this
so i'd like to hear it
the honorable member for burnaby south
yeah
uh
thank you very much mr speaker i'd like
to thank the member for burnaby south
for his uh leadership in successfully
pushing for this important emergency
debate tonight that all canadians uh can
tune into and and see the the important
issues that need to be discussed
that many people have been saying that
the
the federal government has been missing
in action and it's so important to have
this debate tonight i'd like to ask the
member for burnaby south uh two
questions what would he say and what is
his message
to health care workers who have for the
last two years as you said so eloquently
have been struggling to make sure that
canadians are taken care of despite uh
the health care cuts that we have seen
over the course of the last few years
that have been devastating
and what is his message to canadians
that see the ever
ever and ever more long
food bank lineups that are uh often in
precarious situations or have become
homeless that are seeing the increasing
inequality in our country that have been
exacerbated during this crisis what is
his message to those canadians tonight
for burnaby south
thank you for the question
thank you to my colleague uh first i
would say to healthcare workers
you're the ones who have saved our lives
you've put your lives on the line to
care for us at the minimum we need to
make sure that you're safe and i am
deeply offended that the people that
have cared for us have been made a
target by this convoy the people that
have put their lives on the line to keep
us healthy are the ones that are now at
risk of violence if they wear clothing
that identifies them i want healthcare
workers to know that is wrong
that i stand with you i'm going to
continue to fight to make sure you're
respected for your work but more
importantly that you are properly
resourced so you can do the work that
you want to do i've met nurses with
tears in their eyes because they're
underfunded and understaffed and
overworked i want you to know i'm going
to fight to make sure there's proper
funding for our publicly delivered
healthcare system and that the federal
government does its part and to the
people dealing with inequality that has
only gotten worse in this pandemic you
see a rigged system where those at the
top continue to make massive profits
while everyone else suffers that is
exactly why we need to provide solutions
that speak to people we need to put
people at the heart of everything and
that means making sure workers have fair
wages that means we've got housing
that's affordable and accessible to
everyone that means people shouldn't
have to rely on a food bank but have the
dignity to be able to provide for
themselves and their families and have
the supports necessary to live a life a
dignity that's what we're fighting for
you are who we're fighting for and we're
going to stand with you every step of
the way
resuming debate replies dude the
honorable minister of public safety
thank you mr speaker and at the outset
i'd like to indicate that i will be
sharing my time with the prime minister
i want to thank the member for burnaby
cell for his motion and i want to thank
all of my colleagues who are
participating in this important debate
tonight
friends the situation ottawa began as an
interruption and it has now become a
sustained convoy and blockade
and during the course of the last number
of days we've seen far too many examples
of intimidation harassment violence and
hate
the residents here have effectively been
held hostage
in their own city
and many of them especially young women
feel unsafe
they've been blockaded by an angry
loud intolerant
and often violent crowd
now of course all members in this house
support the rightful
the right to peaceful protest and it is
indeed one of the pillars of our
democracy
but peaceful protests do not make people
afraid to leave their homes
and this convoy has done that
and in doing so it has crossed the line
since the beginning
has been there
uh
this
to work
support as the situation is
requested information throughout the day
commissioners to make sure
ottawa mr watson while the situation
remains very concerning on the ground
we have seen progress made
over the last number of hours
we've seen
charges laid
we have seen investigations ongoing
we are seeing um the cutting off of
propane and fuel to participants in the
convoy
and we are seeing structures removed and
we are seeing the dispersing of crowds
safely and respectfully and with the
excellent performance of our law
enforcement
hundreds of charges will continue uh to
be laid where appropriate and those
decisions will be taken
independently by
our police services
in the weeks that follow we will need to
be very clear that we cannot find
ourselves in a similar situation again
mr speaker
we must also be clear that we cannot
expect to yield to the reckless forces
that are outside as a way of imposing
reckless change in public policy
through disruptive activities like the
blockades that we're seeing the bringing
in of heavy equipment and scaring and
intimidating tactics
for now however we must continue to work
together and assess what needs to be
done
i've also been asking for operational
updates through the day as well as daily
updates to make sure that me and my
partners are doing everything that we
can to help restore the rule of law
and i'm confident that today's
announcement of a table being convened
between all orders of government
will help to make sure those on the
ground have all the tools and the
resources that they need to get the job
done
and to see the situation diffuse
colleagues the pandemic is approaching
its second anniversary in canada and i
want to assure you and every member in
this house
and all canadians that we all want to
get back to normal life
and that day is coming
canadians have been united and we've
persevered through it all
our government has taken a responsible
evidence-based approach using science
and using good faith efforts day in and
day out to protect one another
because canadians have chosen this path
thousands of lives have been saved
we cannot allow an angry crowd to
reverse a course that is saving lives
now here in this final stretch
this should never be a precedent
for how to make policy or law in canada
we believe in peace
order
and good government
the stories that are coming from
communities from coast to coast to coast
to people who are looking out for one
another who are sticking up for each
other who are giving back
despite the fatigue throughout the
course of the pandemic
is the narrative is the story of the
resilience and the unyielding spirit of
canadians
and more than ever we need to support
each other we need to work side by side
regardless of the level of government or
party strife to take care of one another
canadians deserve to feel safe in their
communities and i know that all members
will join me in that
in that in that spirit mr speaker
and i will just go on uh to say uh
before
yielding the floor
that
i know this is a particularly difficult
moment
for the residents of ottawa
i know that businesses have had to shut
that families have not been able to take
their kids to daycare
that seniors have not been able to get
around
that disabled persons have not had
access to public transportation
that people do not feel safe
that the reports of intimidation and
harassment and violence and the images
that we have seen over the course of the
last number of days
have been very disconcerting to all of
us
those of us who respect the rule of law
those of us who expect that while we can
hold disagreements
um it is certainly uh never a
justification to cross the line
and to not respect other canadians and
to break the law
and that is why mr speaker
i'm very proud of the fact that this
government since the very beginning
of this convoy
has done everything that we can to put
the resources the support
to our police services locally
including the provision of some 275
mounties who have now been deputized
and who are now able to enforce the law
locally and i want to take a moment to
thank the members of the rcmp
who are assisting the ops
in dealing with this very challenging
situation
mr speaker
i will say that um
given the the the great length of time
that has passed since the beginning of
the pandemic
that of course everyone will feel a
degree of fatigue and we obviously uh
share that sentiment right across the
country
but we should not confuse
the sharing of that emotion and the
sense of wanting to get back to life as
normal
with a lack of respect for the law
and that is where we must draw the line
mr speaker and that is where we will
draw the line
and we do it
because these are the shared sense of
values uh that on which our country is
built on
we do it out of respect
for those
uh who have worked so hard
to see those values and those principles
enshrined in our charter
to ensure that they're not just words on
a page
to ensure that there is a sense of
of unity and common ground
that sees itself manifest
in our daily lives
and we haven't seen that
in the past number of days in ottawa and
i would hope that all members would
recognize that
that it does us no good
to yield to perhaps some of the darker
angels of our nature
we need to be listening to uh the better
angels of our nature especially when
those values are tested especially when
we have vigorous disagreements around
the pandemic but those disagreements can
never be a justification
for this the kind of conduct and the
kind of behavior that we have seen
here in ottawa and that is why
i think i am calling and indeed i hope
all members are calling
on the convoy
to go home
to contribute to debate
but not to break the law
not to make the members of ottawa and
those who live here feel unsafe
that's what canadians do mr speaker
canadians respect the law
no one is above the law
and we will get this through this
together thank you very much
questions
on
and
comments
honourable member for pitt meadows maple
ridge
thank you mr speaker
i'm having a flashback
as i'm listening to this member's
comments got elected in 2019 and shortly
thereafter we had protests with the
regarding the wet sweat
all across canada
billions of dollars were lost and here
i'm hearing
words like this is enshrined in
parliament and rule of law and i can
appreciate that
we don't support radicalism
but i'm just this is extremely rich for
him to make these type of comments and
my question two questions one is has he
gone out and talked to some of these
people i think that they a lot of the
ones when i've wandered there and yes
there is people
there are some people that certainly
they've taken way too far
but
have you gone and talked and have what
responsibility will he and the and the
government take for agitating and
calling racists and and and just
marginalizing
millions of canadians thank you
the honourable minister of public safety
mr speaker with due respect to my
colleague what's ironic is that he says
that he and the members of his party
respect the values of the charter
but then we see
the member of carleton
and other of his colleagues go and put
around
some of the individuals who have been
breaking
the law
who have been intimidating
and harassing
and causing great disruption
to ordinary folks who just want to go
about their daily lives mr speaker and
if my colleague cannot
appreciate the distinction
between having a vigorous debate about
the way in which we are going to get
through this pandemic
and then
crossing the line and using that
disagreement as a justification
for the very flagrant disregard for the
law that we have seen in ottawa then
that is something that i think he and
his party needs to reflect on very
very carefully mr speaker very carefully
questions and comments questions
thank you mr speaker i'd like to thank
my colleague for being here in the house
so this evening it's appreciated
you know it's not federal jurisdiction
that it should be
the city of ottawa or the ottawa
has officially asked for help from the
provincial and federal governments they
did that
decision making and operational decision
making
is this is very clear
the policy
we were
who says
for the respect of the people of ottawa
thank you
so
[Music]
thank you
and then hopefully a very brief uh
response thank you mr speaker very
briefly you know one of the arguments
that we continue to hear um out there is
that it's just a bad apple in the bunch
but yet
incident after incident we're seeing uh
that there are many bad apples uh in
this bunch those that the conservatives
are embracing time and time again i'm
curious if the minister can provide his
thoughts on that argument that we seem
to hear quite a bit
honorable minister in 30 seconds or less
please mr speaker i want to thank my
colleague for the very thoughtful
question and i think it underlines
a pattern that we've seen from the
conservative party
in an effort to minimize
the harm the intimidation the violence
and yes the expressions of hate i heard
one of my colleagues uh
say it just earlier tonight in the
context of this take no debate
we have to understand that there are
certain boundaries that we do not cross
as canadians the flying of confederate
flags the demonstration of swastikas on
our parliament hill is not only an
affront to our values which are
articulated in the charter it's an
affront to everyone that has survived
the holocaust that has experienced
racism and it is a front to who we are
as canadians mr speaker and these are
not isolated incidents
it has been rampant and that is why it
is critically important that we have to
rely on our law enforcement to disperse
this convoy so that we can get back to
life as normal thank you very much
resuming debate reprised
the right honorable prime minister
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker tonight we're here
because parliament is working
we're here to do our job as government
as parliamentarians
because our democracy
is working
just a short time ago
we had an election
in this country
where we asked canadians
how they wanted to keep fighting this
pandemic
and their answer
was clear
canadians chose vaccines
they chose science
they chose to protect one another
because canadians know
that's how we get back
to the things we love
over the last few minutes
across the
is
to get vaccinated
individuals
are trying to blockade
our economy
our democracy
and our fellow citizens
daily lives
it has to stop
the people of ottawa don't deserve to be
harassed in their own
neighborhoods they don't deserve to be
confronted with the inherent violence of
a swastika flying on a street corner
or a confederate flag
or the insults
and jeers
just because they're wearing a mask
that's not who canada who canadians are
that's not what canadians demonstrated
over the past two years
of consistently
continually
being there for each other
the people of ottawa indeed people
across the country
deserve to have their safety respected
and deserve to get their lives back
from the beginning of this demonstration
our government has been in close contact
with the mayor of ottawa and municipal
and provincial officials
so far the rcmp has mobilized nearly 300
officers to support the ottawa police
services and is ready to do more
yesterday the city of ottawa declared a
state of emergency
we're convening a table with the
relevant federal and municipal partners
to further strengthen our response the
federal government will be there
with whatever resources the province
and the city
need
in this situation
transport is working
suffer the consequences
but mr speaker
this blockade
these protesters
they're not the story of this pandemic
they're not the story of canadians
in this pandemic
from the very beginning
canadians stepped up to be there for one
another
to support their neighbors
to support their elderly
to support our frontline workers by
doing the right things by wearing masks
by getting vaccinated
by following public health restrictions
we're all tired of this pandemic
we're frustrated we're worn down
none more worn down than our front line
health workers
who've been going flat out for two years
but everyone's tired of having to wear
masks
having to follow public health
restrictions
families
like mine just last week that test
positive you know have to follow public
health rules have to isolate themselves
nobody wants to do that
i don't know how many conversations
parents have had to have with kids
about not going to birthday parties but
not getting to have sleepovers
this pandemic has sucked
for all canadians
but canadians know
the way to get through it
is to continue listening to science
continuing to lean on each other
continuing to be there for each other
you are shouting
others because they're wearing a mask
do not define what it is to be the
majority of canadians the vast majority
of archives
majority
millions who have been vaccinated
mr speaker every day across the country
canadians step up to get their first
dose
of vaccinations
that is the story of the country
people who've been there for each other
everyone's tired of covid
but these
protests
these protests are not the way to get
through it
it's a fight against the virus
and canadians know the tool to get
through it
is science
is vaccinations
is continuing to do
what people have done from the very
beginning
step up for one another
make the difficult choices
more than ever
canadians need to continue
to be there for each other
to be united i've seen members of the
opposition
call for an end to the blockades
i salute that this is a time to put
national interests
ahead of partisan interests
this is the time
for responsible
leadership
democracy in canada
didn't happen by accident
and it won't continue
without effort
it was a deliberate choice
made decades and decades ago
to come together to respect one another
to be there for each other
and every generation every decade every
day
canadians continue to live that
choosing to support each other
choosing to do what's necessary
to get through another long winter night
to get through another difficult season
to get through a pandemic
we have in this country
a set of rules and laws
principles
we live by
that keep us safe that protect us and
over the past two years we've seen
measures brought in to keep us safe
measures loosened
when things got better
we will continue
to follow public health
advice we will continue to trust science
as canadians work to get through this
that's what people expect
i know people are tired
but we've seen it
through the various waves and they're
receding over the past months
these pandemic restrictions
are not forever
but we have to make sure
that our shared values
and the idea of canadians being there
for each other supporting one another
respecting each other
that has to be here to stay
and that's what we are all continuing to
stand for mr speaker
guess the only come on without
and comments the honorable leader of the
opposition thank you very much mr
speaker and i thank the prime minister
for participating and being part of this
debate
uh
i look at our country mr speaker and
i've never seen it as divided as as it
is now under this prime minister whether
it's regional lines whether it's ethical
ethnic lines whether it's
people's health care choices uh this
this country is more divided than ever
and the prime minister talks about
things like respecting each other and we
are not fighting against each other we
are fighting a virus and i i have two
very simple questions for him
when he decided to introduce the vaccine
mandate he believed it was the right
thing to do does he regret calling
people names who who didn't take the
vaccine does he regret
calling people misogynist and racist and
just escalating and and poking sticks at
them and being so divisive to individual
canadians that he might not disagree
with that he might have thought were
wrong
does he regret that
and will he agree to meet with the
leaders here the other opposition
leaders and myself so that we can talk
about a solution in the way that he's
described mr speaker this is we are in
uncharted charter territory we are at a
crisis point not only with what's going
on out the doors and and across the
country but the country overall and so
much of it is because of the things that
he has said and done does he regret his
words and will he work with us so that
we can find some resolution thank you
right honorable prime minister
mr speaker i think people watching
expect me to disagree with the leader of
the official opposition
i just didn't think it would be about
something so fundamental
she is telling people tonight that
canada has never been
so divided
never been so angry a one region against
another
and i disagree
what we have seen over these past two
years
has been
canadians stepping up for each other in
extraordinary ways canada has one of the
highest vaccination rates
of our peer countries around the world
why and it's not because canadians love
getting needles
it's because canadians trust science
canadians trust each other to do the
right things it's in our national psyche
of being able to be there for our
neighbors being able to push a car out
of a snow bank uh for a perfect stranger
being
leaning on each other these are the
things that define canadians and what we
saw through these past two years
people stepping up for our front line
health workers stepping up for a grocery
store clerks leaning on each other
supporting our seniors supporting our
young people young people getting there
stepping up to do what they could around
the house to help out while their
parents or they're all locked down this
is a story of a country that got through
this pandemic by being united and a few
people shouting and waving swastikas
does not define who canadians are
questions
strong message and unfortunately that's
not what happened over the past couple
of days
protestors
tonight is a perfect opportunity to send
a clear message to the protesters
um
we are here with resources
yes
south
dakota
um
paul
thank you mr speaker i'm very glad to be
speaking to this pressing issue that has
really got canadians glued to their
televisions that the convoy has been
really all over ottawa and across every
major city in canada and we've even seen
it spread to other countries around the
world so i'm very very glad that after
two long years of division on covet that
we are finally beginning to debate uh
this important matter in this historic
house of democracy i did want to begin
my remarks by actually i forgot to say
this right off the bat but i'll be
spending my time with the member from
megantec
um so i did want to begin my speech a
little bit about talking about what kind
of politician i think
you have to be to to make a difference
in this place and i think every mp in
this house has a bit of a different
style
and uh when i first came here i i really
for me i wanted to be a bridge builder
and that really came from when where i
grew up and where i went to university i
grew up in a small farming community in
rural manitoba to four generations of
canadian farmers so i had very
entrenched rural prairie upbringing and
values and then i went to university at
mcgill university in montreal a very
prestigious
elite liberal sort of university and i
met kids from all over the world with
all different political views and world
views and really got a incredible
experience learning about how other
people think about the world and i did
find that often while parties will
disagree and someone will say i'm a
staunch liberal i'm a staunch
conservative or i'm assange mvp there's
actually a lot more that we have in
common and something that i found that
all parties i believe at their core have
in common is that they they do believe
that all canadians and all people of of
this world
deserve to be treated with dignity
compassion
and respect and so that's how i approach
these divisive issues that we as mps
encounter all the time and they never
get difficult or they're never easy to
talk about they're very difficult issues
and i i look to try to build a bridge uh
so that we can come together
as canadians and agree on a peaceful
path forward and that's how i've been
trying to look at the very divisive
situation
in ottawa right now
and
what i'd really like to see is a prime
minister who calls for national unity
last week i spoke in the house
about a lot of the division that we're
seeing in the country between east
versus west rural versus urban and
particularly now during the pandemic
and
we have heard so much trauma from our
constituents if there's any member in
this house that does not believe
canadians have been through trauma these
past two years they clearly have not
been doing their job and listening to
their constituents mr speaker it has
been horrific the things that i've heard
we hear young children who are so
depressed they don't want to eat eating
disorders are through the roof we've
heard seniors and elderly in our care
homes who've opted for medical
assistance and dying rather than live
one more month through isolation and
care homes i have had widowed elderly
women call and cried to me on the phone
of how lonely they are and they don't
want to go on i've had grown
men who've called me crying because
their businesses are falling apart we
know divorces abuse at home alcohol
dependency drug dependency all of these
terrible things are up in our country
because people are just trying to cope
and are breaking down so from that
perspective i don't really see what's
going on across the country it's all
that surprising to me it seems like an
eruption of something that's been
simmering of pain and trauma and
frustration for two long years and
governments have not been listening to
that pain and trauma despite having
rapid tests vaccines and all different
types of tools and scientific knowledge
governments have repeatedly repeatedly
relied on harsh lockdown measures and
divisive mandates
to control this virus meanwhile
we are seeing a prime minister who today
got up in the house and again again
other canadians who don't agree with him
this is a man for six years said
diversity is our strength but if anybody
doesn't agree with everything he says
you're in the bad books and you don't
get a chance to be heard you don't have
a right to be heard and again last week
i brought i brought to the floor of the
house of commons remarks he had said
during that 600 million dollar
unnecessary election he said so many
times before he called that election
vaccines for all those who want them
vaccines for all those who want them
it's a choice he said that repeatedly he
must have said it a thousand times and
then with da within days of calling that
election he was yelling into a
microphone at a liberal rally that you
have the right not to get vaccinated but
you don't have the right to sit next to
someone who is
so
to me
that doesn't really seem like someone
what did he say in his remarks today he
said
this is not a fight against one another
it's a fight against the virus those
remarks mr speaker suggest very
different
very different so when it comes to an
election and scoring political points
and winning votes the prime minister is
very happy to divide canadians and pick
them against each other for their
different personal health use i'm for
when i'm sick and tired of seeing
politicians use this as an evil wedge
tool to rip canadian families apart i
can't tell you how much anger and tears
i saw in the last election that was six
months ago and now it's even worse
neighbors won't talk to each other i
mean christmas family dinners i mean
even if there wasn't lockdowns during
christmas it's almost a nightmare to get
families in the same room now if there's
one person who doesn't share their views
i mean it's it's a nightmare colleagues
at work
again last week i shared the story of a
social worker a young mom i met during
the pandemic
on her friend's step
uh she was uh sharing with me a story
that she got here of the year award last
year and this year she and she had gone
above and beyond to help people during a
pandemic
before there was vaccine she stepped up
here of the year at her job
and now she said no one would talk to
her and she was going to get fired
because of one personal health choice
that she made as much as others tried
there was no convincing this woman
otherwise and i just i don't know how
public health officials and public
officials get behind policies that do
that to canadians
we are one of the most vaccinated
countries in the world and this
government continues to use that as a
budget to get people to submit to their
policies
it's it i've never thought that entering
politics two and a half years ago at a
federal level we would see a government
that was so keen to divide canadians on
something so deeply personal
and as i've said before and i'll say it
again i denounce any hateful and violent
act outside whoever is up to no good
who's ever up to that kind of mischief
and that kind of hateful rhetoric and
those actions shame on you
but what i'm seeing across the country
is people mobilizing because their
governments have not listened to them
for two years they've been experiencing
trauma for two years and no one is
listening to them
so what choice do they have left these
people have all emailed their mps
they've called them
they've been turned down by their mps
i'm sure there's members of the public
from papua new gu from the member the
prime minister's riding who've reached
out who have a different perspective on
this who've been traumatized and fired
from their jobs for a personal health
choice
there are millions of canadians millions
of them
that have been deeply ostracized from
society and when you don't listen to
those people they mobilize and we've
seen protests across this country for
sen for over a century and rightfully so
we have the right to peacefully protest
and i would ask the protesters outside
that they do their best and stay
vigilant to stay peaceful
but we are seeing other governments
around the world
step up
with lower vaccination rates and say
look we hear you you've been traumatized
we're moving forward here's the deadline
this is the plan no more mandates no
more masks no more distancing you can
travel you can live your life you can
hug each other again here's the date
this is the plan here's the threshold
none of that in canada absolutely none
of that from the prime minister
people have been traumatized and they're
mobilizing because they need some hope
they need somebody in this house of
privilege to come down from our ivory
towers and say okay little people we
hear you so sorry we've traumatized you
for two years we're gonna step up and
we're gonna give you some hope here's a
deadline
the member opposite is laughing the
people in this house are incredibly
privileged you've kept pardon me that
member has kept his job
thousands of canadians have lost their
job and he's laughing about his
privilege his own privilege what has he
done to serve members that are
marginalized during this pandemic in his
community mr speaker but laugh at them
in this house of commons shame on that
member
i would
i would ask this government to do
everything they can i asked them this
two years ago in the house
go to other countries see what they're
doing what are the best practices how is
it that other
highly advanced developed nations like
the uk ireland the netherlands norway
denmark germany sweden switzerland how
the united states how is it that they
have all the same tools we have they
have all the economic resources we have
they've done their citizens have done
all the work and made all the sacrifices
why is it that those citizens get a plan
for hope of when we get back to normal
when we get our lives back when the
people outside you think they want to be
here mr speaker
those people don't want to be or they
want to be working but that right was
taken away from them
when is there going to be a plan from
this prime minister was there going to
be compassionate leadership to say this
is what this is it you've done the work
here's the tools we're moving forward
our public health doctors have told us
as well it's time to move forward it's
time to revisit these harsh mandates and
divisive policies
mr speaker i will just end on this i i
i'm very passionate about this i think
we all are from our different
perspectives but i will say i will
continue to be a bridge builder to reach
out to try to understand where others
are coming from and i would i would it
would just be incredible if we could see
members of the liberal party the prime
minister do the same time to build a
bridge mr speaker
president comments questions
mr speaker i just want to first thank
the member from burnaby south for uh
instigating this uh this debate tonight
and for his remarks now the member from
kildona and saint paul knows that the
interim conservative leader the member
from portugal encouraged her party to
not discourage protesters to leave but
rather encourage them to stay and make
the occupation the prime minister's
problem
shortly afterward when confronted with
the horrific and violent deeds of the
occupiers their interim leader recycled
donald trump's hateful and disgusting
torn defros there were good people on
both sides and even tonight in this very
house in this very debate
that same interim leader tried to
stoke the fires of division when asking
again she did this when asking the prime
minister questions perhaps the next
thing the interim leader will say is
she'll tell the occupiers to stand back
and stand down
so mr speaker
the behavior by some of the members on
the side of the member the side of the
house of the members for kildona and st
paul's is been repugnant as the behavior
of those out in the streets so i'd like
to ask the member how in the world she
believes the actions of her leader and
her colleagues
will help to end this unthinkable and
uncanadian disaster unfolding outside of
these very doors
the honourable member for kildonan st
paul thank you mr speaker i appreciate
the the question from the member who
laughed when i said that members of
parliament in this house have
extraordinary privilege we've been able
to keep our jobs actually never seen
that member before so it's great to see
him participating um what i would say is
i'm very proud of our leader for
stepping forward
today and putting forward a call to
action to the prime minister she asked
him today
will he meet with members of the other
parties will they get together sit at a
table and say look like this is
unprecedented this is an unprecedented
demonstration in canadian history it's
time that you get together put
partisanship aside and work together to
see how we're gonna have a peaceful
resolution to this as a critic for
public safety the shadow minister for
public safety for canada mr speaker i
have i have grown increasingly concerned
that without a peaceful resolution and
compassionate leadership from this prime
minister and that member of parliament
that we are going to see this escalate
they're just stoking the fires anyway
there's pouring diesel on it so to speak
and raising the temperature with their
mean with their mean language their name
calling when they should be being
responsible and lowering the temperature
so that's what i'd like to see from
liberal members of parliament and from
that prime minister some compassionate
leadership it's time to get together at
the same table and talk about solutions
questions and comments casino come out
there the honorable member for north
island powell river
well thank you mr speaker and i want to
thank the member for her speech
you know as i walk through this
occupation i often reflect as the
veteran spokesperson for the ndp
on the people who fought for us
who fought for other countries to stand
up and speak out against any kind of
oppression the people who fought
for the freedom to have a protest in
this country
and i know that i just read an article
today that spoke about a veteran
who was so upset to see people parking
on the tomb of the unknown soldier that
he went there to take pictures
of those license plates so that he would
make sure that they were removed and
that those people would be held
accountable
and right now in our nation's capital
both that monument and the aboriginal
monument are surrounded by fences to
protect
those monuments for the very people who
fought for us for us to have the
privilege to stand this house so i'm
just wondering if this member could talk
about where the line is to stand up
against people who are comet causing
concerning violence and doing things
that we should all be appalled by thank
you the honourable member for kildonan
saint paul thank you mr speaker i
appreciate the member opposites uh the
question i think it's incumbent upon all
members of parliament to stand up
against violence and bullying and
divisive rhetoric
and i've seen that repeatedly i have
done that repeatedly particularly when
again we see a prime minister of this
country
who for over a year and a half said that
vaccines for all those who want them
vaccines for all those who want them and
then within days of calling a 600
million dollar unnecessary election that
further divided wounded traumatized
canadians within days from saying
vaccine's a choice he said you have the
right not to get vaccinated but you have
no right to sit next to someone who is
that's the kind of dehumanizing language
that incites people and gets their
temperature up and gets them mobilizing
that is the type of language that is
irresponsible that we need to bring down
that is not a prime minister
who that prime minister should not be
saying things like that and what i would
say to the ndp
is i you know i'm from rural manitoba we
used to vote ndp for decades and you
want to know why
because it was because the ndp stood up
for the marginalized people who didn't
have a voice in this privileged house of
commons
where has their voice been from the
thousands of workers who've lost their
jobs where's the voice for the social
worker who was too afraid to get a
vaccine and lost her job
where is their advocacy for them
i don't know haven't seen it
resuming debates
i thought
canadians who
which
lifting of these measures mr speaker why
well because
it is
to ensure that canadians could stay
safe
two years later
canadians are vaccinated we were asked
to get vaccinated
so two years
the only person to tell us this in the
entire country
i'd have no plans to lift this
foreign
foreign
from the outside
yes
maybe for somebody
foreign
is
[Music]
is
solutions
is
that was
is
needed to
publicly
is
mr speaker our leader said something is
discuss how we're going
so let me get this straight mr speaker
days ago
an email is leaked that the leader of
the official opposition actually stated
that we should that they should not ask
the protesters to leave and instead make
this the prime minister's problem
but now we're led to believe by this
member that the leader of the opposition
is suddenly the one that's bringing
everybody together to come up with a
solution is that what this member is
trying to say
i'm not trying i'm saying it
she is trying to do something good for
canadians and i will support her 100
with that
and it's totally true mr speaker it's
totally true that it is on the prime
minister responsibility what we are
facing right now i stand with that
because he was hiding
for more than a week mr speaker instead
of addressing this
urgent and very very
disastrous matters
questions in the comments
thank you very much
at the same uh
but at the same time
last week last friday
and we got no response from the
government
um
there days a responsibility for the
government
okay
as soon as it arrived
mr speaker focus on one very key point
uh the demonstrations
that are hateful and racist we condemn
those we denounce those
in the strongest possible terms and we
should do this
these sorts of things happen in any
is
thank you very much mr speaker and i'm
very happy to be here this evening and
i'd like to say uh at the beginning that
i'll be sharing my time with the member
for senjohn
i'd also like to thank the ndp for
having called for this emergency debate
i think as i said earlier it's
uh really time that we discuss the
elephant in the room and the elephant in
the room is this occupation of ottawa
and it's incredible that since the
beginning of this protest
we've seen protesters continue to
protest and the parliamentarians
continue to sit it's like two solitudes
and nobody's speaking and in particular
the government is not speaking to the
protesters so we're at a bit of a dead
end so this uh protest against mandatory
vaccines for truckers who need to cross
the canadian american border
has
gotten quite out of hand we're no longer
talking about a minority of truckers
as we all know 90 of truckers are
vaccinated so it's a small minority who
are
their points against these measures but
there are other uh points that have been
brought up there are people who are
protesting against
the uh
the measures put in place by the legal
government or by the true government or
rather by this uh government
and so things have gotten out of hand
there are people who are saying
dangerous things there are people who
are intimidating journalists and the
people of ottawa there
and this uh occupation has become
illegal you don't have the right to park
your car in the middle of the street uh
endlessly and think there'll be no
consequences this uh movement's been
taken over by
conspiracy theorists people from the far
right
and many others and if we go back to
january 29th mr speaker the protesters
met in ottawa and paralyzed
uh the downtown on wellington street a
number of incidents that took place so
there was a protester who was uh
carrying a swastika the brothers
carrying confederate flags uh a number
of protesters uh
parked on the tomb of the unknown
soldier others urinated on that
other protesters uh put their message on
the terry fox statue and other statues
uh protesters also went and took food
from
the homeless in soup kitchens
and
then there's the noise which has added
to
the blockade on the roads and that's
causing problems with people of ottawa
there are people in ottawa who have
organized counter protests there are
businesses who have lost a lot of income
with this occupation of the downtown
a number of people haven't been able to
get to medical appointments because of
traffic that was the case for a little
four-year-old boy from gatineau who
wasn't able to get cancer treatments he
wasn't able to get to his treatment
because of the blockade in downtown
ottawa there are ambulance drivers and
paramedics who have had uh
rocks and insults thrown at them racist
insults there are people
things downtown there's quite a supply
chain in uh for a gas among other things
so this has really uh gotten quite
unfounded we can understand that people
are sick of it the pandemic uh
and health measures are all the same but
we're all tired of them
i have to say that
the protesters
who protested in quebec city did better
than the ones in ottawa
what made the difference here was that
the government was better prepared in
quebec city than in ottawa the federal
government
that
when these
measures at the borders went into place
things might go badly and they should
have prepared when we saw the thousands
of protesters who were physically and
financially preparing
for this
and started heading toward
our capital right in front of
ottawa has failed and quebec
did its job quebec city
if you want to manage a crisis you need
to have two measures in place of
preparation and leadership
in this crisis ottawa has failed while
quebec city
was able to succeed
since the beginning when we've asked the
minister of public safety about this he
said well it's not his job to tell the
ottawa police service what to do and we
know that that's not his role but he
could show leadership
and collaborate with
the police
and in this case we haven't seen the
prime minister at all and we know that
the prime minister had to isolate
because of 19. but
clearly his uh
health allowed him to participate in a
number of virtual activities he was able
to participate in question period he was
able to hold press conferences from his
residence and the only statement that he
made was to say to the protesters well
uh stop commenting
who don't want to get vaccinated to go
get vaccinated well that's not very
and that's certainly stimulated their
enthusiasm to continue their civic
disobedience in the name of their
freedom and to the detriment of the
freedom of the people of ottawa and i'll
come back to the comparison
with uh what happened in quebec city
over the weekend with protests there was
leadership there the government
said upstream clearly that they wouldn't
tolerate anything getting out of hand
the mayor and the police force mobilized
to make sure that everything would take
place calmly and respectfully
they didn't let the protesters set up
camp
by uh sunday night they were all gone
all the protesters but here in ottawa
the protesters are still here and
they're planning to stay why
because nobody is
dissuading nobody of them is encouraging
them to leave it should be the role of
the prime minister and the minister of
public safety to send a clear message
that the federal government won't
tolerate this and that they'll give all
the necessary support to the city of
ottawa and to the police service of
ottawa that they'll make sure that they
are in constant communication with the
government of ontario with the ontario
provincial police and with the rcmp
last week
propose that a crisis group be created
that the government take leadership
safety clearly said in the house on
friday when answering a question from
the leader of the black quebecois
uh
to the police service but the people uh
the protesters are here to speak to the
federal government we should never have
let the protesters set up camp but now
uh that they're there what are we gonna
do well clearly the city of ottawa
is out of resources
the city of ottawa has asked for more
support from the different levels of
government including the federal
government because the municipality
feels uh powerless
given that the protesters are here to
meet with the federal government
they are calling for help
today uh
ottawa city hall voted on a measure to
ask for help from the federal and
provincial government so the message is
very clear and we've been saying it
since the beginning of this siege of
ottawa that uh
you know the city of ottawa and their
police office saying they need more help
what is it going to take for the federal
government to help the minister ascend
to rcmp
members and other 275 officers and
that's good and we're happy about that
but he continues to say that uh it's uh
the mall is in the in the in the city's
court and yes the city does have some
responsibility to take and they're not
taking it
here this
evening we've heard liberals speak
including the prime minister and the
minister of public safety
and they
took advantage of their time to uh
criticize the abusive uh actions that
we've seen as we've all done
we've all denounced
these actions but we would have what we
would have liked to have heard from the
government tonight was what's the plan
the government's going to send more
money to the arsenal be great what else
we haven't heard anything else what is
that the mandate of those officers rgb
is to continue to uh ensure the safety
of people is it to
increase surveillance or is it to end
what's happening uh in in the city of
ottawa to end this siege so this is
a missed opportunity for the federal
government and for the prime minister to
send a clear message to the
people of ottawa and the protesters and
to show that they're in control that
they won't let things degenerate we've
seen abusive actions and we don't want
to see any more but we don't know what's
going to happen next so
mr speaker i'm going to receive a whole
pile of hateful messages uh this evening
based on what i've said because i've
taken a stand against this protest and
it's unfortunate to see our society
divided this way but i'm doing my job uh
in this mr speaker and it's time the
federal government is it's just
questions questions and comments member
for kingston and the islands thank you
very much uh mr speaker and i thank the
member for her intervention today and
her comments um
the first
request that's being made the primary
request that's being made by the the
leaders of this convoy is that
the governor general dissolve this
parliament
and appoint the senate and the governor
general to form a quote
citizen
to form a quote
citizens of canada committee
does this to the member to this member
seem like
a group that can enter into
negotiations with uh effectively
thank you mr speaker i'd like to thank
my colleague for his question
and i would correct him the first demand
the initial demand uh
by the federal government to ensure that
truckers are vaccinated when they cross
the canada us border and so that was
the initial demand
i didn't
see the federal government have a
dialogue on that or attempt to send a
message to the protesters and yes things
have degenerated since then and as i've
said the uh
there are some
ridiculous demands but some are more
legitimate we know that people are fed
up and that's what people are trying to
tell us but to not say anything to them
i don't think that's going to improve
the situation and i don't think that by
saying well
stop complaining and go get vaccinated
is going to
make the truckers get into their cabs
tomorrow and drive
that questions and comments the
honorable member for oshawa
thank you mr speaker and i want to thank
my colleague for her excellent speech
and her sincere desire to find a
solution and work together and i was
upset with the
the liberals lines of questioning to be
adversarial
mr
speaker we know the prime minister
instead of coming out as the member said
to end the vaccine mandates he was
name-calling he was demonizing
dehumanizing these uh canadians and he
has infringed on their charter rights
and freedoms and in order to continue
that he needs to
show that it's demonstrably justified
and mr speaker we're seeing today the
cdc
recognizes natural immunity the who
scientists are saying recommending
dropping these mobility restrictions
john hopkins says that the
restrictions and lockdowns don't work
and dr fauci in the lancet says that
both vaccinated and unvaccinated
canadians trans or people transmit the
virus equally since the delta variant so
the science says that we could come out
with a plan to stop the restrictions get
back to normal would she
support the opposition leaders and the
government getting together to let these
demonstrators know there is a plan there
is a solution there is an end let's end
this together
i'd like to thank my colleague for his
question
but uh that's what the black quebecois
has been calling for uh friends at the
beginning that we create a crisis group
for those who are directly involved in
the ground and we're open to the
government discussing with the
opposition parties because we have ideas
and we're all tired of the public health
measures but the ones that my colleague
is talking about right now most of those
were put in place by the provinces by
quebec in particular so it's not the
federal government who can
uh
get rid of certain confinement measures
because the federal government didn't
put those in place so there are
certainly discussions that can be
[Music]
new variant but there should be some
kind of plan and uh
the
quebec government is doing that they're
going step by step with a de-confinement
plan so maybe we need to see a similar
plan from the federal government at
least for the measures that are under
their jurisdictions
because
short-term political gain has been
making this situation worse the
honorable member
in 30 seconds or less thank you mr
speaker it was an excellent question and
yes unfortunately i think that there are
a lot of people and organizations who
are trying to profit from this and who
are trying to make political gain who
are trying to uh maybe get a certain
base that they lost because uh people
are fed up but you know what everyone's
fed up everyone's tired of this but
there's a certain part of the population
that uh
wants to you know get that message out
more than others and i see that i'm out
of time but i hope that everyone all
elected officials can work together uh
in a solid in in a good way so that we
can get out of this crisis
thank you very much mr speaker and i
would like to start by saying that i'm
very happy to speak to this situation
unfortunately
my colleague outlined that very well so
i'd like to go speak to some other
points uh something that's maybe a
little bit more not necessarily
emotional but
maybe talk to some of the missed
opportunities
because this situation has gotten worse
and more so all those things that we
missed
i would like to say mr speaker that
despite the fact that we are in a house
where there are parties
and that's unfortunately what is going
on right now we've been polarized by the
situation
unfortunately
[Music]
is
[Music]
foreign
form of
[Music]
is
the message itself was diverted
is
what
[Music]
i did it myself
i
required to be vaccinated to go to both
sides of the border
and the protesters
what do you think about the fact that
the protesters making restaurants
you're trying to help them
were cut by the prime minister
[Music]
the situation
intelligent conversation is even
possible we were so polarized that we
felt obliged to say either we are full
or we are against
it wasn't the case in quebec
[Music]
it was done disciplining in a
disciplined way
oh
on what's happening
mutations
[Music]
if the federal
because we've missed amazing
opportunities to have an intelligent
dialogue and intelligent conversation on
the ways to get out of this
crisis and i hope that this evening is
debated
an olive branch that all
parliamentarians
tend to one another so that we remember
the
[Music]
find an end to this pandemic thank you
mr speaker
questions and comments the honourable
member for kingston the islands thank
you very much uh mr speaker and i do
want to thank the member from saint john
for her intervention today um i think
that i certainly uh learned a lot from
what she had to say i really appreciated
the personal account of of the story
that she
uh shared about uh interacting with some
of the protesters um and i think she
makes a really good point
quite frankly and i think i can learn
something from it which is the fact that
there are
many different people out there with
many different uh objectives and
motivations and indeed
she's absolutely right there are people
that have come to this uh protest uh
quite innocently
uh i've seen myself families out there
walking the streets um and
uh and and it's important to recognize
that so i think i thank her for that i
guess the problem for me
is when i'm going to a drug store like i
did and i saw somebody confront
the store clerk and put a camera in
their face and said you can't force me
to wear a mask in here i have rights
blah blah blah like where do we draw the
line like how do i can how do we figure
out how to appease
the people who are legitimately
not trying to um uh create problem
versus those that are overtly trying to
do it i'm wondering if she can share her
thoughts on that
the honourable
[Music]
members for his questions
is
added themselves to the soup and it
turned into something completely
different
[Music]
uh
to keep your questions short and your
answers short so we make sure we get
everybody that wants to have an
opportunity
uh
is
jurisdictions are important but it's not
a reason to not if you did uh
[Music]
i'm sure
collaboration is still great and that's
what we've hoped from the very beginning
questions and comments
can't believe there's nobody else that
wants to
ask a question
i'm going to wait one second here just
to be sure
thank you mr speaker
well it's great because people are
watching cpac this evening
i'm
at the end of the weekend because there
was no such polarization that happened
it was done in a much more cordial way
as i mentioned
we no doubt
[Music]
thank you very much uh mr speaker for
for giving me this opportunity to speak
on this very important issue and a very
important debate
that is taking place as members know
that i represent
the riding of ottawa center
the house of commons where most of you
are sitting
i'm sitting at my home
is located in ottawa center
speaker what we see outside
what we are talking about
for last 11 days happening
is happening
right
in the heart
of my community
although the parliament hill is located
right here in downtown ottawa
many people forget
and perhaps these occupiers have
forgotten
that a block
in all directions
from parliament hill
our residences
there are people
who call
downtown
their home
they're seniors
they're people with disabilities
they're young people
they're families
who live
in downtown ottawa
speaker i have
really have now lost words
as to how i can describe
what my community
is going through
so i thought
perhaps i can start
my remarks today by just reading
to all the members
through you speaker few of the emails
that i have been receiving
just
to give you a glimpse
of the pain
and agony
people have been going through
for the last 11
days
speak i can spend the full 20 minutes
reading you emails because there are so
many
but i do want to talk a little bit about
solutions
in my remarks
so here's email number one
i'm one of the ottawa residents in your
writing
i feel the need to raise my concerns
with you so you may escalate them
through the appropriate channels
the members of the convoy who are
occupying the city have been causing
damage and mayhem across downtown
and i strongly disagree with the police
action or rather the inaction of the
police up to this point
these people from the convoy have stolen
from homeless shelters
vandalized and damaged houses and
businesses that display pride flags
assaulted and harassed residents for
wearing masks during the pandemic
desecrated our memorials launched
illegal fireworks and most recently have
been caught attempting to set an
apartment building on fire while taping
the doors closed
this is just some of the inexcusable
actions that these people have done to
our city and to the residents of our
city
email number two
i have been a resident of ottawa for
over 40 years
never before have i seen such prolonged
aggressive and unlawful behavior
in our community
constant truck horns blaring diesel
fumes engines revving and shouting at
all hours have become
insufferable i am horrified by the
racist and anti-semitic symbols i have
recently seen in my neighborhood
which are unacceptable and have no place
in canada
email three
it should be well understood two years
into this pandemic that disabled folks
are among the most vulnerable to covert
19.
we fall into many groups there are those
like me who are vaccinated but who face
a higher risk of adverse outcomes should
we get infected
others are immunocompromised and get
less protection from the vaccine and
would be less able to fight off an
infection
others still are medically ineligible
for a vaccine
public health measures requiring mask
wearing and vaccine passport have kept
the disabled community safe
they are our first line of defense
this
disabled auto ones have been placed at
serious risks over the past 10 days
given the flagrant disregard for mass
squaring and vaccine passports by
occupiers
places like the redo center as well as
small businesses have closed because
they were unable to keep customers and
their employees safe
email number four
we are constituents of ottawa center and
unfortunately live in the glee our
daughter however is in center town she
was first impacted by the current crisis
when a week ago last friday she was
trying to do an online presentation from
home with a background of ear horns she
moved in with us nine days ago others
have not been so lucky and have had to
remain confined to their homes in the
red zone
one of our daughters visits to check on
her home all she could smell on her
first two floors was diesel fuel
imagine trying to take care of kids in
this situation
one of our daughter's neighbors has
downloaded an app that measures decibels
66 is the maximum before hearing begins
to be impaired
the neighbor's app was reading 72 inside
her home
email number five
i feel unsafe buying groceries as people
are in the store without wearing masks
and behaving aggressively like many
other businesses machines independent
grocer on bank street is dealing with
the protest noise and aggression from
the public as well as possible increased
exposure to covet 19 omicron from those
not wearing masks
while taking on the cost of hiring extra
security i feel bad for the cashiers and
security staff who have remained patient
and calm under these dire conditions
i'm exhausted while the last 23 months
of the pandemic have suddenly been
challenging working from home during the
week with all the noise from the
protests has become aggravating while
not being able to enjoy a short walk or
a quiet afternoon indoors over the last
two weekends has truly become depressing
mr speaker
i can
go on
i can write you 5
10 15 20
100 more emails
people pleading
for peace
people who are peace loving people who
understand that we live in the nation's
capital and peaceful protest protest
is part of our democracy
but not
that is something of this nature as
something that is nothing short of an
occupation
something that is unlawful
and definitely
not peaceful
what people have been asking in my
community is that
have we forgotten that we are still
living through a global pandemic
in fact we are still
going through a fifth wave
with restrictions around us
to ensure
that we do not get ill
and that we do not
over burden our health care system our
and our health care workers
sometimes i wonder when i hear some of
the debates some of the arguments coming
in this house especially from the
official opposition
that something like
kobe 19 pandemic never happened
that somehow things were normal and we
just all decided to change the rules
around us
speakers we all have gone through a very
difficult time it has not been easy for
any one of us especially those who have
been vulnerable and marginalized
and yes we need to have a conversation
around what lies ahead how do we end
this pandemic how do we get to a place
that it becomes an endemic and how our
lives will be impacted by that
but that debate does not take place in
the form that is happening right now
outside
the house of commons
that's not a debate
that's us just holding a community
hostage
that is now how you engage in a
meaningful conversation and a respectful
conversation
speaker i am not interested in speaking
to somebody who waves a swastika
or a confederate flag
i have members of racialized and
jewish community in my writing who are
and i've used this word before
rattled they're scared
they're re-traumatized and victimized
none of us believe that we are actually
seeing those images
in our hometown
our nation's capital
speaker i urge all the members of this
house you are all respectable good
people with the right motivation to
serve your communities to build a better
country
to please come together
to please
ask these occupiers
to leave my community alone to restore
peace in my community they want to
engage in a conversation have a
conversation but we cannot have a
conversation when a whole
set of neighborhoods
are being held hostage over the last
11 days
this
protest
this occupation
this civil unrest
has to come to an end
it has to come to an end for the sake of
people who live in this community for
businesses who have suffered so much who
are looking forward
to opening on january 31st when the
provincial
lockdown measures were being lifted
and they are unable
to do any business
they are closed
have we thought about impact on them
and their families
how they're going to make ends meet
i'm grateful to my colleagues
ministers
the member from arvanier
uh
the president of the treasury board who
are working closely
with me so that we can find ways to
support our businesses
where they are now
had a double hit
to them
as a result
of this occupation
so speaker in my limited time i want to
focus on what can we do
how can we get out of this
i'm already pleading to all of us to
let's work together
speak with one voice
be rational people that we are
to ask these occupiers
to please leave and then engage in a
process where they work with their
elected representatives
where they
hey perhaps run for office themselves
if they feel so strongly that we need
better laws and better policies
but in a democratic society that's what
we do
but in the near
moment that we're living right now
speaker
we need to make sure
that this occupation ends and one of the
the ways we can do this is by ensuring
that laws are being enforced
the ottawa police has been working hard
and they are responsible
for providing
the safety and security of the residents
of ottawa
that is their job by law that's what
they're required to do and it's
important for them to enforce the law
municipal laws provincial laws federal
laws all three of them have been broken
i am a lawyer by professional speaker
i've been the former attorney general of
ontario i can give you an entire list of
laws
that have not been followed through and
we need to make sure that enforcement is
there if resources are needed has they
have been requested as the federal
government has been providing those
resources to them
from day one we will continue to do so
i've been involved in this from the
moment this protest has started and i
have to tell you working with minister
of public safety working with the
minister of emergency preparedness
including the prime minister who've been
engaged who have taken the time to speak
with me about this issue
we've been there for city of ottawa and
the ottawa police service to give them
the resources they need
so the laws could be enforced
we saw some enhanced law enforcement
starting last night i really hope
that that enforcement remain in a
sustained fashion
so that peace could be returned back to
our community
so that we could
ensure that the members of my community
can go back to living the way
they lived
but we need to enforce the law that is
what the members of our community are
asking for we need to make sure that
there's a plan
and this occupation is put to an end
speaker there's no doubt that there's
going to be a fair bit of conversations
that are going to take place after
this occupation is done and it will come
to an end
we will do as we always do rightly so
learn from
from
incidences like these from mistakes made
things done well things done not so well
and we shall do so in this circumstance
as well as you can imagine as a member
for ottawa center i am already
starting to think
how can we do things differently in an
appropriate time i will be presenting
ideas speaker
that we need to consider so that
we can protect our democratic
institutions
that we can find ways to promote
peaceful protests as is our democratic
right
but also be able
to safeguard
the right to live peacefully for
the residents of downtown ottawa the
constituents that i'm so honored to
serve
and one of those ideas speaker that i
will be
speaking
to the members
to the house
is perhaps an evaluation of
parliamentary precinct
right now we define parliamentary
precinct as
parliament hill
and some of the buildings that are
located on wellington street and spark
street maybe we need to study
increasing the boundary of parliamentary
precinct
so that we can have a better robust
safety protocols in place
not take away
lawful peaceful protests which are
critical to a democracy
but ensuring
in a way that we do not run into the
kind of circumstances
we are running in so i will be
indulging members my colleagues
into a conversation
where we
analyze and study better whether we
parliamentary precinct needs to have a
more bigger footprint
and better protocols in place as to how
we ensure
that a whole downtown
is not
held hostage
speaker i hope
you've been able
to see
the challenge that i am going through
but most importantly speaker i hope that
i have been able to channel some of the
emotions of my
constituents
sometimes it's hard to express in words
what my community is going through
sometimes it's really difficult to hear
the other side and speaker i've always
said that i want to listen to the other
side
legitimize
this occupation as something as civil
or peaceful
when people are suffering
they've been they've had a rough time
almost over the last two years because
of pandemic and this has made their life
unbearable
speaker i urge
you i urge through you all the members
of this house
to let's stand together by the end of
this debate
and collectively ask for these
people to leave
we can engage in a civil conversation we
can hear each other and agree to
disagree but this is not the way to do
it i implore you i urge you please leave
our community alone please let people in
ottawa center in downtown ottawa live
peacefully thank you very much speaker
questions and comments questions
the honorable member for kamloops
thompson caribou uh thank you mr speaker
always a pleasure to rise on behalf of
the residents of kamloops thompson
caribou on this important topic
uh mr speaker the honor roll the
honorable parliamentary secretary made
two points that i wish to follow up with
him on they're both relatively brief the
first is mr speaker he said let's work
together and i note that the official
leader of the opposition tonight sent a
letter to the prime minister
and to all party leaders to work
together so based on that would the
honorable parliamentary secretary be
prepared to advise the prime minister to
do just what he said we should be doing
secondly
the
audible parliamentary secretary said the
police should be enforcing the laws does
he view it as the prime minister's job
to tell the police what to do in this
situation
the honorable member for ottawa center
thank you very much uh speaker and i
will address the second question uh
first i i think the member opposite
knows quite well that in our system of
democracy
politicians do not tell
our police officials as to how
to enforce the law
there is a very important significant
and healthy distinction and
differentiation between the two i have
the honor of serving as the solicitor
general of ontario i very much know
speaker that you cannot tell police
how to operate so i would be very
careful
in suggesting that somehow the prime
minister should tell ottawa police
service or any other police service for
that matter as to how they should apply
the law
as for working together of course we
should work together and i look forward
to looking at the reading of the letter
but i think the member opposite should
also listen
to the
to the health care experts to the
medical experts as to why it is
important
that we get vaccinated and put an end to
this pandemic thank you that's the only
comment questions and comments
below
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
the honorable parliamentary secretary
well thank you very much speaker and and
i think the member opposite is
trying to say that somehow this is a
political problem
speaker we're living through a pandemic
we have we have a health care challenge
at the moment
this is a global pandemic
canada is not alone in fighting this
pandemic
this is happening across the world
so to suggest
that
the way to deal with the protest outside
is by holding daily press conference i
don't understand how that was going to
put an end to this crisis
what's needed is to ensure
that the laws that we have created and
you and i are part of creating those
laws
are properly enforced
and if somebody breaks the law
then they
should face the consequences of
breaking the law and that's what we it's
required in ottawa at this moment i'm on
the ground i'm
out in there trying to find solutions we
need to make sure the laws
are enforced this is an unlawful protest
which needs to end thank you
questions and comments questions
the honorable member for victoria
thank you mr speaker i want to thank the
member for a speech
when i talk to constituents they are
tired and frustrated and disheartened
that we are still in this pandemic but
the vast majority of them are following
public health guidelines they are tired
and fed up with people who refuse to
wear masks refused to follow public
health orders putting others at risk
people at ottawa as the member mentioned
are beyond tired and fed up experiencing
harassment and assault witnessing
anti-semitic and fascist symbols women
being threatened with rape residents
from racialized and
2s lgbtqi
a plus communities having discriminatory
slurs hurled at them canadians are also
concerned hearing reports of an
attempted arson in the lobby of a
residential apartment building it's
terrifying does the member agree that it
should not have taken this long for the
prime minister to start talking to
municipal and provincial governments the
convoy organizers were clear about their
intent they were allowed to do exactly
what they said they would do does the
member understand why ottawa residents
are tired and fed up with this liberal
government
well member for ottawa center
thank you i thank the member for for for
her comment and and i i will agree to
with her on the point is that
canadians have made a lot of sacrifices
and they are following
the public health guidelines they are
getting vaccinated they are wearing
masks they are
socially distancing themselves it's
amazing i have two young children it is
amazing to see the kind of habits
our kids have developed their good
habits
good hygiene as a result of this
pandemic but a lot has been done
but i also want to assure the member
that since the beginning of this crisis
the prime minister has been fully
engaged
i've had conversations with him he's
being briefed
but
the prime minister
as the
head of government
does has no power to tell police
how to deal with the situation
our law is absolutely clear
nor we want in our system of democracy
having politicians tell police
what laws they should be
enforcing and how it's our job to create
the law
and an independent police
role is to enforce the law and in fact
independent judiciary to arbitrate
whether the application of the law is
correct or not
but i can assure all the members
that the prime minister has been engaged
the prime minister uh
is fully informed and briefed and making
sure that this crisis gets over as
quickly as possible thank you question
and come on there are questions and
comments the honourable member for
halifax thank you very much mr speaker
and i i just want to tell the member
from ottawa center that uh
my heart is breaking for for him and for
his constituents it's hard to imagine
taking what's happening here in ottawa
and putting it in
in
halifax a city that i love as much as he
loves his city
and seeing the kind of damage and and
terrorizing of of neighborhoods
damage to property
illegality
going on i can't it's just must be so
incredibly heartbreaking and uh so many
of our hearts go out to you now the
member's in a very unique position being
the the member of parliament for the
most directly impacted part of the city
but also as a former attorney general
for the province in ontario uh he
alluded mr speaker to some of the
changes that he'll be bringing
proposals for changes that will be
bringing forth in due course um i'd love
if you could give us a sneak preview on
the flavor of some of those i i he
mentioned changes to the parliamentary
precinct the elimination of vehicles off
of wellington street and the
pedestrianization of that street would
be a remarkable innovation but even
changes to the operating procedures of
this house to to better manage some of
the um activities of members we're very
interested to hear that thank you
the honorable parliamentary secretary
thank you thank you speaker i think the
the member opposite uh you're absolutely
right i am i'm
i along with the member from auto veneer
and in the heart of this crisis
and uh
as i mentioned the community suffering
is is unbearable is is
you i'm i'm starting to run out of words
uh to explain it um and that's why i
think as soon as this crisis over we
need to inside engaging in thinking
about the future and how to prevent
things like that by ensuring that we
create an environment where
uh we have peaceful protests which is
again
i want to stress as a democratic right
and so one of those things and one of
the interesting things is everybody can
imagine about auto is multiple
jurisdictions you know we've got the
parliament of canada which is the
government of canada and then uh you
have the municipal service too and so
from street to street jurisdictions can
change a park is owned by one federal
entity and a street next to it is a
provincial uh provincial or municipal
street and so what we need to look at is
the the boundaries of parliamentary
precincts so we can
uh perhaps better coordinate
but you just uh the member uh speaker
just said something which is being a
deep desire of mine that we need to look
at finding ways to convert wellington
street into a more a pedestrian street
to make sure to beautify it making it
green so more people can enjoy the
beauty of parliament hill as opposed to
being able to drive their cars and
perhaps even occupy as we've seen in
this instance
continuing debate representative the
honourable member for wellington halton
hills
thank you mr speaker i will be splitting
my time with the member from sherwood
park fort saskatchewan
mr speaker
canadians have
the right to protest
protest has long been part of our
democracy
so important that we enshrined it in the
constitution
in the four fundamental freedoms
enumerated
in section two of the canadian charter
of rights and freedoms
all canadians have the fundamental
freedoms
of conscience and religion
a free speech and expression
of association
and of peaceful assembly
the freedom to protest in the public
square
whether on a sidewalk or in front of a
legislature or in a public park
is a fundamental freedom
and so if canadians individually or in
groups want to protest
by walking up and down wellington street
or by standing around the centennial
flame in front of parliament
they are free to do so
millions of canadians over many decades
have exercised this fundamental freedom
but what canadians do not have the right
to do
is to blockade
there is no right to blockade
there is no right to blockade a street
there is no right to blockade a highway
there is no right to blockade in
international border crossing
there is no right
to blockade the construction of a new
pipeline
nor is there a right to blockade a rail
line
there is simply no right to blockade
and canadians do not have the right to
harm other people or enter to interfere
with the freedoms
of their fellow citizens and while
freedoms are fundamental they are not
unlimited
freedoms are limited by what harm they
do to other people
and freedoms are limited
by how they interfere with other
people's freedoms
mr speaker we are a nation rent asunder
west against east
rural against urban
those unvaccinated against the
vaccinated
we are a nation divided because of a
lack of leadership
leadership that begins at the top
the prime minister needs to reflect on
the language and rhetoric that he has
used over the past six months that has
so divided this country
rhetoric that has referred to over three
million unvaccinated canadians in
disparaging terms
rhetoric that suggests that those who
disagree with him are not canadian
rhetoric that has poured rhetorical fuel
on the fires of division
that are pitting one canadian against
another
friends against friends
family members against family members
those unvaccinated against those
vaccinated
those in favor of mandates against those
opposed
those calling for an end to restrictions
against those in favor of restrictions
and while many
have fanned the flames of division in
this country
they are not the head of government
they are not the prime minister of a g7
country
the prime minister's rhetoric in the
last six months is unbefitting the high
office of this land that he holds
instead of bridging divides in reducing
tensions and lowering the temperature
he has demonized the other
mr speaker
it is time for the protesters
to end the blockade in ottawa
and the blockade at the border crossing
in western canada
it is time for the protesters to go home
to their families and their communities
we have heard their concerns
we have met with some of them
and it's now time for them to go home
their concerns have been heard loud and
clear
and no doubt in the coming weeks their
concerns will be debated here on the
floor of this democratically elected
legislature
mr speaker canada
is a country founded on the trinity of a
belief in freedom a belief in democracy
and a belief in the rule of law
and in a free and democratic society the
rule of law must be upheld
in this case the governments in this
country have delegated the enforcement
of the law
against blockades
to the police
i encourage the protesters blockading
here in ottawa and at our international
border crossing to follow the direction
of the police
in a democracy only the state is
authorized to use force
including lethal force to uphold these
fundamental freedoms
that we enjoy to uphold the rule of law
we have delegated this use of force to
law enforcement
in our democracy citizens are not
entitled to use force
as citizens we settle our differences
through the ballot box or through the
court system
we don't settle them through force
mr speaker we all bear responsibility
for the current divisions in this
country
we all have a responsibility to reflect
on how we got here
i grieve for my country
instead of peace order and good
government
we have chaos
disorder and poor government
and while many democracies are under
pressure both from domestic and foreign
forces canada has been particularly
buffeted by an inability to respond
the pandemic has laid bare the state of
our institutions
and they are weak and ineffective
for most of the last year we did not
have a governor general because of
scandal
eight of the most senior members of the
canadian military were forced out in
scandal
the former clerk of the privy council
resigned in scandal
we have a military procurement system
that cannot procure and we have payroll
systems that cannot pay
and we have a parliament that cannot do
its job because the government defied
four orders of this house and its
committee for the production of
documents
we have a debates commission
that ran in the last two elections what
is almost universally
acclaimed as the two worst set of
election debates
since election debates were first held
in this country in the 1968 election
the people's republic of china
interfered in the last federal election
and spread disinformation through
proxies leading to the defeat of several
candidates and nothing has been done
we have some of the highest levels of
household indebtedness in the world and
governments in this country are not far
behind
last
two years ago less than two years ago
some provinces in this federation had
trouble raising cash on debt capital
markets to pay police officers and
nurses and the federal government had to
step in to bail them out
we have the second worst health care
system
amongst leading economies of the oecd
according to the commonwealth fund
greenhouse gases continue to rise each
and every year that this government has
been in power to a record high level in
2019 the last year for which we have
data and in the early months of this
year it looks like we will once again
break through records with record high
levels of emissions we haven't met our
nato commitments in decades and now
russia is about to invade a democracy in
eastern europe
and now we have a national capital in
paralysis
and the seizure
of an international border crossing the
hallmark of a sovereign state
mr speaker we have gotten to this place
because we have not been serious
we have not been serious about the rule
of law we have not been serious
about ensuring our democratic
institutions reflect the diversity of
views in this country
we have not been serious about domestic
policy we have not been serious about
foreign policy mr speaker
it's time we got serious
questioning
questions and comments the honourable
member for london north center
thank you very much mr speaker and thank
you to the member for his speech
i wanted to ask him a question relating
to vaccine mandates given the fact that
rates of hospitalization continue to be
a challenge
in canada how does the member feel about
vaccine mandates
the honourable member for wellington
halton hills
mr speaker
i believe
that we should encourage all canadians
to get vaccinated
vaccines are a miracle of modern
medicine they are safe and effective and
they are a critical tool to emerging out
of this pandemic
and we should encourage canadians to get
vaccinated through nudges
through encouragement
but not by demonizing them and singling
them out
and i think that is the leadership we
need from this government as we go
forward to emerge from this pandemic
question come onto our questions and
comments the honorable member for
mirabella
foreign
setting fire to somebody's house because
they complained about the noise
everybody in this house recognizes that
because that's the first step
uh finding a solution to the crisis in
front of you
thank you uh mr speaker for the uh
question and comment
uh
canadians have a responsibility
uh
[Music]
that is a sign of the strength of our
democracy questions and comments
questions
going online to the honorable member for
nanaimo lady smith
thank you mr speaker mr speaker
listening to my colleague i cannot help
but think of a quote made by desmond
tutu that says if you are neutral in
situations of injustice you have chosen
the side of the oppressor mr speaker can
the member explain how he can stand by
silently ignoring citizens being
harassed and assaulted in their
communities
standing silently while displays of
racism and anti-semitism are waved in
the streets of ottawa paralyzing a
community with hate and fear mr speaker
can the member share when he will begin
standing up for those oppressed and
experiencing hate and racism
the honourable member for wellington
halton hills
thank you mr speaker i want to thank the
honourable member for her question quite
simply i believe
that the blockades are illegal
i believe that the blockade here in
ottawa and at the international border
crossing in kutz alberta are illegal and
i believe that
it's up to law enforcement
to uphold the law and ensure that these
blockades are taken down at a time in
choosing of law enforcement
governments and
cabinets in this country do not
direct law enforcement
as to their
actions
we empower them with delegated
authorities to enforce the law and so
whether it's
arson
whether it's harassment
whether it's
violence
we have to ensure that law enforcement
has the tools and resources necessary
to do the job
and
i have confidence in the premier of the
province of ontario
i have confidence
in the law enforcement agencies
and the institutions of the federal
government
that they will do their job and put an
end to this crisis
representable continuing debate the
honourable member for sherwood park for
saskatchewan well thank you mr speaker
it's a pleasure for me to be able to
speak to the house tonight about the
ongoing convoy
protest movement that's happening across
the country as well as about the federal
mandates that have spawned this response
and let me say at the outset that i
think it is so important when people
have disagreements about important
public issues that they take the time to
talk to each other and try to understand
each other's perspectives and if there's
a particular challenge at doing that in
canada it's because we're such a vast
country people in different regions with
different kinds of experiences or
perspectives that are informed by their
region have a maybe harder time engaging
in that dialogue with people who live
very far away uh and
this is i think maybe further challenged
by the fact that we're a bilingual
country so sometimes it's harder to have
those conversations across those
experiential regional or linguistic
divides yeah there's something about
this convoy movement that has suddenly
uh shrunk those geographic divisions
because people have come from all across
the country to be in ottawa uh to to
express significant concerns that they
have
so members of parliament now have an
opportunity to go out and talk to some
of the people who are here and to ask
them why are you here to look at what
signs and symbols they're waving or not
waving and to take that opportunity to
engage in that dialogue and what's
incredible to me
is that by all indication there are many
members of parliament many many people
who will participate in this debate
tonight who don't seem to have really
taken the opportunity to look around to
try to talk to people to try to
understand
it
and i would challenge any member who
hasn't done it
tonight tomorrow go outside there are
people right in front of this building
and ask them what's your experience did
you lose a job did you have a family
lose a job did you lose a business
did someone you care about get affected
by this in some way do you know someone
who's experienced suicidal ideation for
the first time because of lost
opportunity or a social isolation that
came about as a result of the pandemic
what are the experiences in your life
that have led you to come and take this
fairly drastic step there are many
people i know here who are protesting
for the very first time
so let's try to understand let's ask
those questions
mr speaker i i got the call from
sebastian in our lobby who does great
work for us on the conservative side at
about 6 45 telling me that i would have
an opportunity to speak tonight so as i
was thinking through what am i going to
do to prepare
usually i sit in my office and look
things up and work in front of my
computer but but instead what i decided
to do is just go out and talk to people
and i've done a little bit of this
before but try to be intentional about
asking people what has brought you here
and what are the things that you maybe
are seeing reflecting the conversation
that are not representative or are
representative because i think it's
again it's important for us as members
of parliament to take that opportunity
to try to understand it many people told
me that they came here because they are
deeply concerned about
mandate policies they believe in this
core principle of individual autonomy
the individual ability to make choices
about your own health without being
threatened with job loss as a result of
it and i think it's objectively the case
that canada's approach when it comes to
vaccine mandates is far more draconian
than many other countries around the
world for instance countries in europe
have a uh have an alternative that's
based on natural immunity
and yet canada
doesn't seem to recognize that so it's
interesting for me because you could say
well this is the science we we're not
including natural immunity because it's
the science and yet it's the same
science in europe or it should be it's
the same virus right so these are these
are legitimate questions why don't we
have the option to consider natural
immunity to consider a rapid test that
would allow people especially truckers
people who are working alone or public
servants who are working from home why
aren't these reasonable accommodations
when an individual wants to exercise
autonomy over themselves and their own
body i think those are reasonable
questions
but you know i had a lot of
conversations with with different people
when i was out just talking to some of
the people who was there i met i met a
young man who actually voted ndp in the
last election i don't know if he will
again after some of the things that have
been that have been said
um i i talked to people a little bit
about some of the uh the the the
questions raised in in the media about
about hateful symbols because we've
we've certainly seen some of those
photos and what i was told is that
in the in the very small number of
instances where people put forward
symbols of hate they were actively told
by other protesters put that away we we
don't want to see that here that's not
representative of what what we're doing
objectively if you walk up and down
wellington street what you'll see is
people waving canadian flags you'll see
you'll see people with various signs
expressing messages about mandates
and
you know and i'll tell you mr speaker
my grandmother was a holocaust survivor
so so i think particularly for my family
the fact that somebody was walking
around one one person maybe two people
were walking around with a swastika i
think that's that's incredibly offensive
and obviously that that strikes
something in me that's that's different
from other members who don't have that
same family experience the reality is
that that
these individuals were told to leave by
other protesters we're told that they
were that they were not welcome there
that their message was not the message
that other people were trying to present
i spoke with a young man who's at the
protest uh who told me he was gay he
told me he brought a a pride flag with
him and he wasn't bothered by anyone no
nobody had a critical comment about that
and i spoke with with many people who
were visible minorities i spoke with a
number of of uh of jewish gentlemen who
had come from montreal to see the
protest and
you know there
there is this representation in the
media
and in the comments of other members
as if this is just a sea of people all
waving confederate flags or something
and that's just not what's happening
objectively whatever side you're on
that's just objectively not what's
happening
so
let's let's start by just looking around
and listening to what the objective
facts are on the ground here
trying to understand what the source of
those concerns are
and maybe recognizing that
that people who have lost their jobs who
are being told they cannot work alone by
themselves
in their truck
they can't work from home as a public
servant that they they can't travel
in in the context of a family emergency
or whatever the case may be people that
are affected by these mandates who are
prepared to take other precautions like
get a rapid test
uh
that they may have a point i think they
do have a point i agree with them in
saying that these federal mandates
should end
mr speaker we should end the federal
mandates not because of the protests but
because it's the right thing to do to
end the federal mandates because the
federal mandates simply don't make sense
as policies when it comes to vaccination
now we've talked about the impacts that
these mandates have had on other people
and our party has consistently taken i
think a very reasonable approach in
saying that employers should take
appropriate measures to secure the
safety of their workplaces
if you are uh in the public service for
example if someone is choosing to
exercise their autonomy not to get
vaccinated then they should take a rapid
test if they're coming into the office a
lot of people are still working from
home
but the availability of testing is a
good alternative and in fact we know
there are many breakthrough infections
right uh and and so even for those who
are vaccinated getting regular rapid
tests is a pretty good idea i would
think it would be reasonable under the
circumstances of the omicron variant for
example to say rather than having a
vaccine mandate for air travel that
simply everybody has a rapid test before
they fly now we've had problems with the
availability of rapid tests because the
government only discovered rapid tests
it seems about two years into this
process and now they want to be
congratulated for oh two years later
we're procuring rapid tests right and
two years from now we'll be having
better ventilation in schools well folks
you're too late you're just too late
we should have been talking about rapid
tests right out of the gate deploying a
system of widely available rapid tests
before the vaccination was even
available
and then we would be ahead
mr speaker we could be where other
countries are many other countries many
other jurisdictions around the world are
now lifting their restrictions
completely
and yet the government is continually
talking about ways to further tighten
mandates
to further squeeze the very small
portion of the population that is not
vaccinated the fact is the vast majority
of canadians have gotten vaccinated
the small minority who have chosen not
to get vaccinated i think it's fair to
assume at this point they're probably
not going to get vaccinated
so at this point it's time to say well
we have the reality of covet it's going
to be with us most people are going to
choose to get vaccinated some people are
going to choose not to we believe in
this principle of individual freedom and
autonomy
and we can't
function very well as a country if the
government continually wants to to fire
and otherwise penalize people who
exercise their autonomy
so i would say it's time to lift the
mandates and it's time to work towards
getting back to normal
of course we can continue to take
appropriate precautions in response to
events that come up
but the level of restrictions on
individual freedom the level of coercion
is not something that i think any of us
would have thought possible in this
country two years ago
these were supposed to be temporary
measures
but now mr speaker it very clearly is
time to move on it's time to look to the
future because continually finding new
ways to squeeze that small minority of
the population who's not who are not
vaccinated isn't going to change
anything it's not going to move us
forward it's not going to actually allow
us to get out of this
mr speaker people who have never
protested before are coming here to say
they want to be able to work they want
they don't want to be fired from their
job for exercising personal autonomy
they don't want to be seeing empty
grocery store shelves they don't want to
have long delays for accessing
immigration services because people are
being laid off because of these mandates
mr speaker let's end the mandates
because it's the right thing to do
yesterday
questions and comments uh the honourable
member for
london north center
thank you very much mr speaker in debate
obviously we exchange points of view and
here's a point of view i wanted to quote
mr speaker
it reads as follows i spent the week
undergoing the siege of ottawa i asked
that we clear the streets and that we
stop this occupation controlled by
radicals and anarchist groups
those are the words of the previous
conservative party's
shadow critic for public safety a member
of this house to the member opposite
does he agree with his calling or not
the honorable member for sherwood park
for saskatchewan well thank you mr
speaker i think i made my views very
clear in this speech i think that
members should take the opportunity i
think this member to take the
opportunity to go out and engage in
dialogue and and try to come to an
understanding of of what are the
significant concerns here but what i've
really focused on in my remarks is the
fact that we should be ending mandates
that the the continuing squeezing of
that minority who have chosen not to get
vaccinated and all the impact that
that's having on on access to services
we're seeing significant backlogs for
immigration services in our offices and
backlogged accessing other services and
you know when you when you put people uh
who are working from home
on unpaid leave and don't allow them to
provide services that they've been
providing we can't pretend that that's
not going to have an impact
when you when you take trucks providing
essential services off the road that's
going to have an impact these mandates
are having a severe impact on vaccinated
and unvaccinated people alike and they
need to end
come on
well thank you thank you mr speaker and
i i do want to be clear because i didn't
mention this specifically but i do want
to be clear that i think it's it's
critically important that um people be
able to protest and that we minimize the
negative impact on the lives of people
in this city that there be effective
dialogue between protesters in the city
that allows the necessary access and
transportation to occur and i think that
dialogue can take place if if the prime
minister plays a constructive role in
bringing down the temperature this is
the national capital people should be
able to protest here and there has to be
a a space at the same time for that to
happen in a way that's respectful so i
think there are many people uh that want
to see that those kinds of accommodation
happen through dialogue and i think it
can happen but that's different from
saying that that people shouldn't be
able to be here or demonizing the
importance of the message they're
presenting
let's join commander questions and
comments uh the honourable member for
churchill kawadanuk ascii
thank you mr speaker i found the members
speech not just bizarre but deeply
concerning first off the minimization of
the
hate and
violence we've we've heard of over the
last number of days he goes on to talk
about the people he spoke to making it
sound like it's a group of boy scouts mr
speaker you know everybody has talked
about uh the the occupation that our
nation's capital is under it's
international news
and and what canadians expect is
leadership from their politicians
calling on these folks to leave and uh
and allow for people to live their lives
free of hate and the lack of safety they
face and what's deeply concerning is the
concern number of conservatives insist
in on
shifting this conversation to talk about
vaccine mandates etc this debate is
about calling for an end to the
occupation uh and and also condemning
the foreign money american money
fueled by trump supporters that are
supporting this occupation will this
member condemn the use of foreign funds
fueling a hateful and violent occupation
in our nation's capital
honourable member for sherwood park for
saskatchewan well thank you mr speaker
to hear that that member found my speech
bazaar is a high compliment indeed
the the member raised the issue of uh
foreign money and i'll just take this
opportunity to say the member i would
love to see a consistent approach taken
by parties opposite when it comes to
foreign funding and foreign influence in
our democracy let's have that debate
let's see that legislation come forward
because i know that that that member
could maybe take a little bit of a
stronger position when it comes to the
interference of the chinese government
in canadian affairs
i'd like to see that member take a
stronger position when it comes to
issues like the uyghur genocide and
other cases of that foreign interference
happening here in this country uh let's
let's talk about addressing foreign
interference i would love to see a
stronger and consistent policy on that
issue continuing debate representative
the honorable parliamentary secretary to
the government house leader
mr speaker and i'll say at the outset
that i'll be sharing my time uh this
evening with the member from parkdale
high park even though the member from
sherwood park for saskatchewan would
like me to speak for 20 minutes
unfortunately it'll only be 10 minutes
uh this evening um and i will note that
he still has not invited me on the
podcast that he touts so much when he's
in the house i'm still waiting for my
invitation uh no don't worry i'm not
checking my email three or four times a
day looking for it or anything
um
mr speaker i am very uh glad to
participate in tonight's debate and i
think i'm going to
take the opportunity to present some
facts because i think that facts are
extremely important i think that there
is
a lot of misinformation out there and i
think that it would be beneficial to put
on the record some of the facts it's
been said once tonight but i'll expand
on it slightly 90 of truckers have been
vaccinated you know mr speaker i drive
uh to and from ottawa uh in my uh
to get here i drive uh from kingston to
ottawa and back and i have seen
on both occasions of making that travel
since this protest began
countless truckers that are working
right now as we speak traveling up and
down the 401 or whatever major highway
in the country they might happen to be
in in order to move goods uh around our
country 90 of truckers are vaccinated i
actually believe mr speaker that this
inception of this protest this convoy
probably started from
a place that was genuinely about
truckers
and about concerns that they had but
unfortunately
we've seen this morph
into something as it's been hijacked by
other groups and as so
well pointed out by one of my
conservative colleagues uh in a tweet uh
uh over the weekend
whatever the objective was it's been
lost by those that have hijacked this
protest unfortunately and that's the
reality of the situation that we're in
you know
the uh
i find it interesting i heard the member
from sherwood park fort saskatchewan and
a number of conservatives this evening
talk about these mandates i mean his
word these mandates need to be ended
the mandates as it relates to
proof of vaccination the mandates as it
relates to um
you know you know hospital workers those
are all
provincial mandates
it's ironic
that
the opposition would encourage
protesters out front of this building to
protest something that at least in
ontario belongs in queens park
but they do it anyways as a matter of
fact the only mandate
that the that the federal government has
in place
is a mandate that says if you cross the
border
into canada including truckers
you need to show proof of vaccination
but guess what
the united states of america has the
exact
same
mandate
so before you even had to present your
proof of vaccination to a canada border
officer on your way into canada you will
have had to shown it on your way into
the united states leaving canada right
and that's the irony of it that is
the
mandate
that the federal government has as it
relates
to this particular protest as it relates
to where all this angst began but yet
my concern is that the opposition
continues to throw fuel on the fire the
member from sherwood park fort
saskatchewan these mandates these
mandates he knows full well
that the mandate
of crossing borders for truckers applies
to the us just as much as it applies to
canada so i heard from across the way
well why do it then well that's the
whole point of working with our g7
partners that's the whole point of
working with the united states so that
we do have fairness and equality as it
relates to what the rules are to move
back and forth and that's what makes it
work so well
well
the member brought up my electric car if
he if he wants we can talk about that
for a while too but i'm not sure you
know why a conservative would want to do
that when we're talking about such an
important debate tonight as it relates
to truckers specifically and as it
relates to what we're seeing out there
but you know what we are seeing mr
speaker is we're seeing a number of
people
that are
hijacking this protest you know the
member from sherwood park for
saskatchewan
said earlier and i actually think it was
a really good comment and he talked
about
why are you know why aren't more members
of parliament getting out there and
talking to these people you know he's
that he's trying to show and open a door
there the problem is mr speaker is that
this particular protest although i have
no doubt
there are some well-intentioned
individuals participating in it have
attracted a lot more uh behavior that we
all would agree is extremely uh
problematic extremely troubling and and
quite quite frankly uh uh quite frankly
um behavior that we don't we will do not
accept as being canadian so i'll tell
you an example mr speaker
[Music]
i'm really having a hard time hearing
the member the member does speak very
loud but i'm having trouble uh hearing
them so we can just sort of keep it down
be respectful and uh we'll continue on
the honourable member for kingston the
islands thank you very much mr speaker
and so where was going with this is that
although
there there might be some uh well
meaning and well-intentioned individuals
out there i can't help but i can't help
but think of just the other day when i
was in a in the rexella at the corner of
metcalf and o'connor
i was in there
and
we had i saw a protester i'm
i have to assume that the individual is
a protester i should make that clear
uh shove a camera in front of the
clerk's face saying you can't make me
put on a mask i have a right not to wear
a mask who do you think you are like
this individual was going
you know they brought this
fight to the people of ottawa to a store
clerk who's literally just working there
doing her job
and i couldn't help but say to the
gentleman as i was leaving
why are you bringing this fight to her
your fight's not with her she's just
doing her job and i trust that my
conservative colleagues and any member
of this house would do the exact same
thing and that brings me to
the last point that i wanted to bring up
as it relates to this particular issue
mr speaker is that for some reason
the protesters don't realize that those
that they are affecting the most by this
are the people that live
in downtown ottawa
listen
i don't know if we should tell them this
mr speaker but we cannot hear the
honking in here
as a matter of fact you can walk in here
early in the morning
you don't hear a single thing and this
was all last week too
you don't hear a single thing in here
you don't and you almost forget that
it's even happening until you get up and
and leave and go outside and you see it
again
meanwhile
all of the activities that have been
going on and then on the weekend when
members of parliament aren't even the
vast majority aren't even in ottawa
these events continue to go on and on
it's impacting the people that live here
i mean most protests
seek to
get more people on board by delivering a
message seek to find find more
supporters to come and join their cause
most protests that would come to ottawa
here and come to the the front lawn or
to the centennial flame or wellington
street do so in a way that isn't meant
to
develop a following on the way but
instead this protest has come here
and just
completely
made the people that live here irate
with what's going on
and so i believe that it's time for this
to end i believe that it's time for the
protesters
to
recognize the fact that they've made
their point and now it's time to
dispense of the activities and to go
home
thank you mr speaker
question and commentary questions and
comments the honorable member for oshawa
thank you mr speaker the canadian
charter of rights and freedoms
guarantees the rights and freedoms set
out in it subject only to such
reasonable limits prescribed by law as
can be demonstrably justified in a free
and democratic society mr speaker my
colleague talked about the science and
the availability of these mandates that
the liberal government has put in
especially uh infringing upon canadians
mobility rights i have a question for
him
the rationale for restricting canadians
charter rights with these uh mobility
restrictions is that vaccinated people
don't spread covet and unvaccinated do
spread covid now mr speaker that was the
belief before but the the science the
updated science
uh spoken by dr fauci the lancet
research shows that vaccinated and
unvaccinated persons
will transmit the virus equally the cdc
recognizes natural immunity could the
minis could the member please
present the scientific rationale for
continuing these mandates and let's get
on with it let's solve the problem that
we're faced with today verbal
parliamentary secretary if the member
feels as though
charter rights are being infringed upon
there is a building about 200 meters
from where i stand where he can argue
that case
that is where
he should take his issue of charter
rights being infringed upon
not encouraging people to continue
honking the horn
honking their horns on the street
shooting off fire works uh in the middle
of a night in a downtown uh a heavily
urbanized area
go go to
go to the supreme court and fight the
case there that's how we do it in a
democracy not occupying a downtown core
of a nation's capital
hey commentary questions and comments um
we're going to go online
repatriate
the membership
[Music]
um
[Music]
i am disappointed to hear
the a member from the block quebecois
suggests that um
we should try to open up dialogue with
individuals who have been
spreading hate uh who have been
associated with people that are
spreading hate uh people that are fla
you know waving flags that have
swastikas drawn on them people who are
raiding
soup kitchens to feed themselves because
sometimes somehow they're entitled to
that food people who have been
desecrating a war memorial statue people
who have been dressing up terry fox's
statue like i just i like it's not one
bad apple mr speaker this is a whole
host of problems and here we have a
member from the block of aqua saying why
are you sitting down and talking to
these people they're literally waving
flags around that say f and the prime
minister's name come on this is not
the member must know that there are
starting points to negotiations into
sitting down with people and there are
lines that can be
passed and several lines have been
passed in that regard
we have time for a really really really
short question here and answer the
honourable member for port moody quickly
thank you mr speaker and i just need to
revisit an important comment from my
colleague from churchill there is a
sinister component to this illegal
occupation it involves hate
foreign money influence in our democracy
so my question to the honorable member
is will the government take this
seriously and address with integrity the
sinister and dangerous factors these
past 11 days have exposed
elementary secretary i would love to
find out the answers to some of the
questions that the member mentioned i
would love to see some form of
investigation into seeing where the
money came from uh where the activities
were generated and where they started i
think that that's a very important but i
am not going to presuppose that i know
the answers uh to those in advance
because that would just make me a
conspiracy theorist which i believe
we're seeing quite a bit from across the
way
continuing debate representative the
honorable parliamentary secretary to the
minister of international trade expert
promotion small business and economic
development thank you very much and mr
speaker it's a pleasure to join this
evening's debate and
we have a point of order from the the
member for uh saint paul keldone yeah
the member who just spoke just just said
blatantly for on the record that members
on this side tonight are conspiracy
theorists it's a pretty significant
claim we are here representing canadians
he's calling what we've said conspiracy
theorists can he point to one example of
us being considered here right actually
i think we're descending into into
debate i'll go back to the
we're getting we're getting into debate
thank you
listen i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna
stand here for just a few moments until
people cool down just a little bit um
this is a long debate we're still about
a little a little over halfway through
and i know that uh that there's there's
tremendous respect in here that we need
to make sure that uh each so each person
that has something to say has the
opportunity to say it so
let's try not to be inflammatory let's
try not to accuse people of things but
let's try our best to uh
talk about the emotions and the uh the
instances that we're hearing the
honorable parliamentary secretary
thank you very much mr speaker it's an
honor to participate in tonight's very
important debate about a very pressing
issue and about a very uh important uh
event that's occurring right outside
this chamber and has been occurring for
the last eight days or so i wanted to
thank the member for burnaby south for
actually bringing and initiating this
emergency debate
mr speaker let me just start by saying
as somebody who came to this chamber as
a practicing lawyer who worked in
the area of constitutional law and human
rights for 15 years prior to first
getting elected that the right of
protest in any democracy is sacrosanct
that is fundamental in any democracy
it's protected under section 2b of our
charter of rights and freedoms with due
reason and the issue about speech and
protected speech is that it's apex when
you're talking about political speech
that is the highest form of speech that
deserves the highest amount of
protection that's entrenched in supreme
court jurisprudence
what is problematic mr speaker however
is when
speech
demonstrations and protests
veers into hatred now i don't want to
overstate the case we know that there's
been some instances of hatred perhaps
not all of the protesters are engaging
this but it does taint and flavor and
characterize what we're seeing when we
see it on a repeated basis and what have
we seen we've seen swastikas and we've
seen the confederate flag and what do
those mean mr speaker well the swastika
is obviously a symbol of the third reich
it harkens back to nazi germany it's a
very vilifying and detestable
manifestation of what that regime
represented and what it did to jewish
people
all sorts of minorities racialized
persons religious minorities lgbtq2
communities people who are roma etc the
confederate flag obviously represents
the institution of slavery and we heard
very eloquently from the member of
hawaii umar how that feels for a person
of black skin for a person who is
racialized how that feels for a person
like me brown-skinned muslim man who
takes his place in this house those are
symbols we don't need here and what does
it mean mr speaker it means that what we
have devolved into and we've heard about
this repeatedly this evening for the
people of ottawa for even the people
here who work in ottawa such as me mr
speaker it's starting to look a lot more
like an occupation than a protest
when you destabilize people when you
disturb them intentionally when you honk
horns just to aggravate individuals as
the member who just just spoke the
member from kingston islands indicated
the fight has been taken not to the
government but to the people in the
residence of this city and that's
problematic mr speaker because it starts
to affect people's behavior perhaps
that's what's intended here mr speaker
to have a chill on people's behavior but
i think it's problematic when a
storekeeper can't open their their
storefront a cashier is worried about
working at rexella and when even members
of parliament my colleagues and even
dare i say and dare i admit myself mr
speaker that when i went home after the
ukraine debate the emergency debate one
week ago i was concerned for the first
time in my seven year parliamentary
career about who i might encounter at 10
30 at night on the streets of ottawa
that's not a pleasant place to be in mr
speaker and i think that's what
unfortunately this has been driven to
the next point i want to make mr speaker
is that it's important
it's always important to take issues
with policy positions that's what a
democracy is all about that's a good
thing
what has been thankful is that at least
with that protest outside people
some people had the good sense to carve
out a lane of traffic for emergency
vehicles that's also a good thing but
what i've still seen and what we've seen
last summer this past fall now this
winter even just yesterday mr speaker is
that the people that drive those
emergency vehicles are being targeted
they're being targeted with acts of
hatred acts of violence acts of
harassment
people shouldn't fear wearing their
uniform mr speaker we talk about the
people who are in uniform who are
keeping us safe and they deserve to be
credited there are other people wearing
uniforms called scrubs mr speaker when
people are cautioned about wearing their
scrubs in public the people have been
keeping us safe the people who swear
hippocratic oath to keep everyone safe
no matter how heinous their attitudes no
matter how vile their positions may be
people that keep everyone safe both the
people that are vaccinated and the
people that are unvaccinated those
people deserve our respect
appreciation and gratitude and it is
exactly the opposite that some people
are forcing upon them right now i'm not
saying all people but some people that
has to be stopped in its tracks mr
speaker i want to inject a third aspect
into this discussion which is about the
notion of trucks
being filled with gasoline being parked
50 meters from a legislative building
such as the house of commons i'm
speaking to you from mr speaker we know
i know
muslims know mr speaker the trucks have
been used as instruments of death and
terror around the planet
and what i'm saying here mr speaker is
that we have to question things such as
unconscious bias in terms of how we
approach parked vehicles loaded with
gasoline very approximate to a
legislative building because i don't
think it's vast speculation or venturing
a guess here to say that if those were
black protesters indigenous protesters
if those were if those were muslim
groups if if i could finish thank you to
the member from forza's sherwood park
for saskatchewan if those were muslim
protesters calling for peace in the
middle east
i venture a guess that perhaps the
enforcement the reaction of law
enforcement wouldn't be to let trucks
idling filled with gasoline
idle for eight straight days outside of
the parliament buildings so there's
something some food for thought to
inject into this debate but the last
point i want to make again
i guess i have to speak over the people
opposite because they don't want to
listen is that i find there's an
inherent illogic in a lot of these
protests
now i've asked a couple times here
already just to sort of hear people out
you all have the opportunity to ask
questions you all have the opportunity
to get on the speaking list i see some
of you are all ready to go so let's take
the opportunity to listen and uh and
make comment and ask questions when we
have that opportunity the honorable
parliamentary secretary
thank you
so the inherent logic in terms of what's
going on outside and there's about six
points i'm going to make and i'll make
them quickly first of all the amount of
federal lockdowns that have been issued
in this country in the last two years
are exactly zero they are provincial
jurisdiction first point the second
point is is that if you're that
concerned about trucking mandates you
might want to take notice of the fact
that those mandates are applied across
the continent as the member from
kingston islands rightfully pointed out
there is one that applies to getting to
the united states and now there's one
that applies to come back from the
united states the third point is that it
seems puzzling to this lawyer's mind as
to if your intense philosophical
position is that lockdowns are
problematic and should be issued then
why are you causing a lockdown in
downtown ottawa and by virtue of your
actions preventing the storekeepers from
places like spark street wellington and
the rideau center from opening it is
inherently illogical the fourth point
mr speaker is that what i find puzzling
is that the party of supposed law and
order the party opposite her majesty's
official opposition is doing exactly the
opposite in terms of maintaining law and
order in this country what we've seen
instead and i know they're gonna start
they're gonna start they're gonna start
talking because maybe they don't like
what i'm about to say but their interim
leader has actually said let's not tell
them to go home let's instead make the
prime minister wear this one that's
right so instead of encouraging law and
order and enforcement of the law they're
encouraging exactly the opposite what i
find also puzzling mr speaker is that
the official opposition prides itself on
being the party of fiscal prudence but
the last tally that i heard mr speaker
this
protest quote unquote is costing the
good people of ottawa the city of ottawa
and the auto police service about eight
hundred thousand dollars a day
in terms of fiscal produce that's not
fiscal wisdom i i'm very impressed that
a member a physician
no less than a physician is seeking to
heckle me from across the way because he
isn't happy with what i'm talking about
[Applause]
i don't know why we've descended into
that we've had great debate up to now
and for some reason we've descended into
uh into a lot of heckling
i would appreciate it if we just let the
member finish it up he's only got two
minutes and 21 seconds left um and you
guys uh the the the members will have
the opportunity to ask wonderful
questions
the honorable parliamentary secretary
mr speaker and what i would point out in
terms of a fifth inconsistency is that
the members opposite like to pride
themselves on constantly issuing foreign
interference we heard this come up only
in the last 30 minutes what i recollect
even prior to my time in politics was
lots of concern about things such as
foreign money flowing into this country
with respect to environmental protesters
particularly with respect to the alberta
oil sands i do find it puzzling and a
little bit inconsistent that there's
much less concern about foreign money
that has been declared to be flowing
into this country right now in support
of what these people are calling a
protest and that is money coming from
florida and money coming from texas so i
do find that inconsistency a bit
puzzling and to weaken
my friends opposites position but let's
get back to maybe some place where we
can find a meeting ground there is some
discontent clearly some of that
discontent has been vomited in the form
of hatred which thankfully everyone has
issued in this chamber i think we could
be doing it a little bit more forcefully
but what i do think we need to do is get
to the stage where we understand that
the point has been made and the notion
of taking a city hostage and occupying
it and taking your concern with perhaps
my government or this side of the aisle
and manifesting it and vomiting that
kind of protest against a cashier rexall
against a storekeeper the redo center
and against the people in the city that
are just trying to go about their daily
business and get some rest has gone too
far that is when the protest loses
credibility and unlike exactly as the
member from kingston the islands put it
normally protesters want to gather
momentum what they've done is exactly
the opposite they've created people who
don't see them as credible don't see
them as legitimate and want them to
leave the point has been made i think
the time for the convoy is over so we
can get down to the business of
producing better policies and better
politics for this cheap within this
chamber for this entire nation thank you
mr speaker
questions and comments casting
commentary the honourable member for
cumberland colchester well thank you mr
speaker i appreciate the opportunity to
rise in this very important topic
you know i i really find it very very
fascinating that the member opposite
would suggest that somebody over here
drove those trucks there that's really
quite fascinating that we're somehow
responsible for this uh and and that
we're responsible for ending it i
believe that this evening our leader
actually sent a letter to the prime
minister imploring him to join the
leaders of the other parties such that
we could come to a peaceful and urgent
conclusion to this so and i guess the
other thing that's interesting mr
speaker is my honorable colleague
michael chung sorry my honorable
colleague who spoke earlier
thank you very much the other owner
member cross appreciate that uh the
other honorable member down down the
road who i can't remember where he's
from but that being said uh
thank you very much uh the member
opposite actually was not here to hear
his speech in which he said very clearly
that we agreed with law and order and
this harder i i i i'll let you ask i'll
let the member ask the question in a
second but you cannot refer to someone
being here or not being here so i know
just retract that and ask ask the
question help member for call chemical
chester i'm sorry for saying that the
member was not here i really apologize
for saying that he wasn't here uh that's
unfortunate
you can't you you can't you can't you
could just unreservedly apologize for
him
whether whether someone's here or not is
irrelevant
the honourable member of a cumberland
culture i'm very sorry for saying those
things that i said previously over and
over again i apologize for that mr
speaker you know the unfortunate thing
is is when we have these debates perhaps
the
everybody should pay very close
attention to what's happening mr speaker
and that would make the debate much
better so will you get your prime
minister out there to talk to these
people
make sure uh
to the member of cameron culture to make
sure that when he asks a question he's
asking it through the chair not directly
to a member the the parliamentary
secretary
so
three quick responses no one accused the
member opposite or his colleagues for
driving the trucks outside second point
is that attempting to resurrect his
interim leader in terms of what she may
have said today does not eviscerate what
she said last monday which is that we
should take political advantage of the
situation not discourage people to leave
and indeed make the prime minister aware
this as his problem that is a matter of
record that has been reported by
multiple media outlets and thirdly i
actually find it quite puzzling that the
member opposite given his vocation as a
medical doctor is not appreciating the
simple fact that if people of his ilk
are afraid to wear scrubs
in public and are being told by law
enforcement not to wear scrubs in public
because they might be targeted we have a
problem generally and we have a problem
for those in his profession who i hope
he would stand up for thank you mr
speaker i contact questions and comments
a little bit
matapedia
point of order the honourable member for
cumberland colchester
upset
quite possible that i don't know the
rules but i'm quite sure that ilk is
really not a favorable term that that i
should be called in this great house of
commons
uh i guess we're descending into debate
uh debate a little bit um
thank you very much mr speaker and i'd
like to thank my colleague for his
question he was referring
to go see what these people are living
in
health measures you know what we've been
talking to our fellow citizens for the
last two years
every level here in this country the
municipal provincial and federal levels
the compartment
the politics
have always been based
on experts
questions and comments the honorable
member from nunavuts
i wanted to thank the member for
acknowledging that uh the ndp have a
great leader and our member for burnaby
south
uh unfortunately i can't share the same
sense of
acknowledgement for the liberal
leadership
the liberal government has shown a
history of either inaction or responding
to
issues too slowly some of which include
them having made promises to address
indigenous housing to flow funds for
housing so that there's
less overcrowding and of course to
the extremist activities at the hill
can the member commit to ensuring that
uh implementation of the four-point
solution that our mem the bernie south
addressed and when he asked for this
emergency debate which first is to calm
the situation at the hill and then to
end with the ensuring that there's a
strategy to
making sure that uh canadians live
move to a sense of normalcy so that we
can make sure that
first of all he meets with the municipal
leaders that he addresses the
interference with funds from foreign
states and to make sure that provinces
and territories are have this the
honorable parliamentary secretary with a
very short answer yeah thank you very
much mr speaker i thank the member for a
question remember opposite for a
question what i would say to her is
simply that as of yesterday we had an
announcement from the prime minister
that a table is being struck with
respect to leadership from all three
levels of government that is exactly the
type of cooperation we need because we
are seeing a situation that is very
concerning for the city of ottawa and
for all ontarians and all canadians
thank you i praised you but
continuing debate the honorable member
for york simcoe
[Applause]
blake simcoe thank you mr speaker and
i'll be sharing my time with the
honorable member from brandon surrey i'm
glad we're having this debate this
evening it's a very important issue and
it's necessary to address the growing
sentiment that exists right here across
this great country
canadians are frustrated mr speaker
they're sick and tired constant
shutdowns lockdowns restrictions
mandates are having a terrible toll on
our country's population
this toll is now becoming far beyond
that of covet 19 itself
after two years we know that covet 19 is
not going away
that's why we have to use all the tools
at our disposal
so that canadians can live healthy
normal lives and businesses can reopen
unfortunately the liberal government has
failed in its handling of the pandemic
and now they are failing to provide
canadians with a credible plan to get
life back to normal
even as countries around the world drop
their restrictions and mandates
even as they put forward plans to help
their
citizens learn to live with covid the
federal liberal governments persist with
policies and practices here in canada
that no longer make sense
over 90 percent of the population has
been vaccinated already
and we know that vaccines have limited
utility in preventing the transmission
of the omicron variant
instead of putting forth a credible pan
plan the liberals continue to sow
division and resentment among canadians
they ignore the widening gap between
those on guaranteed government salaries
like themselves
in those who are only able to work
if the government lets them
there is a widening gap between those
who live in rural canada
and everyone else a gap between
low-income workers and those at the very
top
between homeowners and renters and the
haves and the have-nots
it's no wonder canadians are angry and
frustrated it's no wonder that after two
years that frustration has led to one of
the most significant protests parliament
hill has ever seen the freedom convoy of
trucks and other vehicles that it was
assembled outside from coast to coast
they are here
at parliament as is their right
protesting the policies of the federal
government
they are doing this outside the federal
building and protesting provincial
policies outlined outside legislative
buildings across the country
i would note mr speaker that this is the
appropriate place to do that
they aren't outside private homes or
cottages of mps or premier's homes
the prime minister may not want to speak
to those protesters but i have mr
speaker i've spoken to many of them i've
read their signs and listened to what
they are saying
and one thing is abundantly clear
it's not just the protesters outside in
the provincial capitals across the
country
who have these so-called unacceptable
views
these views are held by
these views are not held by some fringe
minority
i've heard these opinions from my own
constituents
canadians from all walks of life have
real concerns about how the liberals
have handled this pandemic and want to
know what the government is doing to put
covet 19 behind us
instead of addressing these concerns the
prime minister his government and some
in the mainstream media have labeled
them as racist misogynist extremists
just to avoid scrutiny for the liberal
government's numerous failures
unlike the prime minister i believe the
most important job i have as an elected
representative is to listen to the
residents of my community
just as it is his job supposed to listen
to the citizens of this great country
over the past few weeks i've heard from
the owner of a local gym in bradford
nine round
who was in tears she's been shut down so
many times she can't even count
she now owes thousands of dollars in
rent with no relief available to her
and no confidence that anything will be
changing anytime soon
i've heard from an elderly man in
keswick who is eligible for no coven 19
support and forced to eat kraft dinner
now
five days a week for supper
because he can't afford to buy proper
groceries
as inflation continues to rise
he told me mr speaker he never thought
his retirement would look like this
i've heard from a couple in jackson's
point who returned from a cruise near
egypt owned to be locked up in a
quarantine hotel for days on end
with no clothes and no access to
life-saving medication
i've heard from families in mount elbert
who experienced the pain of losing a
loved one to covet 19 and seniors in
sutton who have been isolated in
long-term care homes and other
facilities for the past two years
without the ability to see their
families or the outside world
i've heard an expected single mother in
holland landing who provided for her
family
through her job
in a federally regulated industry she
was fired because she made the decision
that she wanted to wait to get
vaccinated after she had her child i've
heard from parents in bondhead whose son
hasn't been the school in 18 months mr
speaker
every single one of these people has
real stories
valid concerns about where our country
is after two years of covet 19.
many canadians are hurting right now
many have lost their jobs they've lost
friends and families and lost faith in
their government and institutions and mr
speaker they deserve to be heard
my constituents in new york simcoe and
canadians across the country have
diligently followed public health advice
made sacrifices done what's necessary to
keep their families and communities safe
throughout this pandemic
they have done their part now it's time
for the liberal government to do their
part it's time for a re-examination of
the government's coven 19 response in a
more sustainable path that gets life
back to normal and gives canadians
hope for the future
what does that path look like it's clear
that more must be done to ensure that
those most vulnerable are protected
as best we can from the coronavirus
but that can be done without devastating
and ineffective lockdowns and mandates
that [ __ ] the economy and impact the
lives and livelihoods of canadians
i spent most of my life working as a
restauranteur i know the challenges and
triumphs that exist in the industry
it can be hard to make ends meet and
keep your doors open in the best of
times but when the government has shut
you down and prevented patrons from
coming in it's no wonder many have
closed their door first good
instead we need to be looking at
alternative policy approaches that will
keep canadians safe while strengthening
our economy and respecting individual
freedoms
in summer of 2020 my colleagues and i in
the ontario conservative caucus were
criticized by state media the liberals
and the ndp for examining an innovative
rapid test
that health canada had not approved
after months of delays
despite being available in the u.s and
across europe
we were looking for solutions
and to hold the government count so it
could be the best it could be
but instead of addressing the prolonged
rate delays at health canada and instead
of looking at best practices of other
countries government members opted to
criticize
ridicule and ignore
that's why it's no surprise those same
rapid tests and many like it are still
hard to come by
for most canadians today two years later
but it's not just rapid tests we need
better medical approaches that focus on
treating those who are suffering from
covet
not just fruitlessly trying to stop its
transmission
right now we have some of the worst
health care capacity in the g7 and our
system will remain strained because of
delayed surgeries and other procedures
where's the plan for that mr speaker
where's the funding for the provinces
but no matter what is done to
specifically address coveted 19 going
forward one fact remains
most of us hate to see the country that
as a state it's in today
it's hurt and it has divided us
that's why it's important that we
restore a sense of unity in canada a
shared commitment to one another it's
time to put aside the divisive rhetoric
and policies and politics that drive
wedges between neighbors family members
and friends
there needs to be a recognition that we
are all in this together once more as we
look towards a future
this is what our country needs and it
requires the right kind of leadership to
make this happen
canadians are telling us that they want
this parliament and they want it to work
together while representing every part
of this country and the people who live
here
and they are telling us they want to see
a government that is committed to
collaboration accommodation and a
willingness to listen
mr speaker i hope the prime minister is
listening
questioning our questions and comments
we're going to go to zoom the honorable
member for king's hands
thank you mr speaker and i'd like to
thank my honorable colleague from york
simcoe for his remarks tonight through
you to the member opposite you'll
forgive me if i thought i was sitting in
queen's park as the member opposite
highlighted
the school closures
the gym that was facing troubles and of
course businesses i presume he won't be
voting for doug ford in the upcoming
election in ontario because that is the
government that is imposing those
elements what i will agree with the
member opposite of course is that we do
need to transition beyond covet dr
teresa tam is talking about that right
now as our other chief medical health
officers but my question is this
going back to the protest in february of
2020 this member highlighted of course
the wet soweton protests and the
economic cost of what the blockades were
representing
he said that in committee it's on the
blues for the record
my question to him today is he not
concerned about the economic cost of the
blockades that we're seeing in ottawa
indeed in other places and why has he
not spoken up for these protesters to go
back home the honourable member for new
york simcoe
well i thank my honorable colleague uh
for the question
you know
pointing out uh the provincial
um let's say lockdowns to this
i'm trying to show the government
the people that are outside right now
are hurting
okay
this is what has all led to this this is
the frustration
that people have people are crying in
their businesses right now
literally crying mr speaker you know the
gym i talked about that the member
alluded to she owes the forty thousand
dollars she showed me scott my payment
is hundred and thirty one dollars for
this i have
six hundred dollars in my account and
i'm shut i can't make money and she's
sitting there crying in front of me this
is the frustration we have out there on
the streets right now mr speaker and i
wish my honorable colleague would go out
and talk to some of these people and
listen to them
mr come on
questions and comments
thank you mr speaker i'd like to
the situation and the situation facing a
number of his constituents but
uh off the street
when the politicians are using the
crisis uh
to their advantage
on that does he think that it's putting
oil on the fire to see politicians
trying to make gains off the crisis
thank you mr speaker i thank my
honorable colleague for the for the
question you know what no one should be
making political gains off this this is
where you know again i spoke to it in my
speech we are in a minority parliament
canadians have sent us here to work
together and quite frankly come up with
a solution for this you know today um
our leader put forth a a suggestion to
the prime minister that we should go out
and and meet with these people canadians
don't want to see um these convoys
anymore and you know these are the
conversations about new government
policy about mandates so we all have to
have together mr speaker you know the
government will keep alluding to 92
percent of of canadians are vaccinated
90 of truckers are vaccinated you know
people will ask the question it's okay
to ask that question now you know scott
why am i being put in in a corner if
it's 90 percent why the mandates
why the mandates and they keep alluding
to the united states i don't take my
marching orders from the u.s mr speaker
i'm time for a 30-second question and a
30-second answer and the honourable
member for vancouver east
well thank you very much mr speaker and
i thank the member for his comments he
says that he doesn't take his marching
orders from the united states well with
the convoy what we are understanding is
that there's a lot of money coming from
the united states so does he agree that
that should be stopped and in fact this
is going to be brought up at committee
uh as an issue from the ndp and would he
agree that funding from the united
states should not be going to the convoy
and it should be stopped
for the question and it's my
understanding mr speaker that that is
being studied at this time and being
looked at thank you
continuing debate representative the
honourable member for brandon soros
[Music]
thank you mr speaker and thank you to my
colleague from york simcoe for uh used
to wading into deep waters and he's done
a great job of speaking on this one
tonight as i rise today unfortunately i
rise with heightened awareness of just
how divided canadians have become
this emergency debate is predicated on
that very reality
a lot of people are angry right now
on any given day i hear from people who
think that we have too many restrictions
and i also hear from those
who want even further imposed
in all my years in politics i've seen
i've never seen such heated debates
which has caused a lot of tension in
families and in communities throughout
canada
to clear up any misunderstanding i am
vaccinated i believe they are safe and
have helped reduce hospitalizations
i believe they have saved lives
particularly those who are older and
have underlying health conditions
i have also
encouraged others to get vaccinated
but i want to be able to question the
liberal government's covet policies
without being labeled anti-science
anti-vaccination or without being
discredited because i have the audacity
to criticize government policies
for too long we have been given a false
choice that either we acquiesce to every
government measure or we are only
lending credibility to those who spread
false information
the one thing i know for sure is that
the political environment we now find
ourselves in
is directly related to this mindset
without a doubt cover 19 has been hard
on all of us
families have lost loved ones and many
individuals have suffered or are
suffering illness
families in my constituency have been
prevented from driving across the border
to be with loved ones
university students have been unable to
set foot in a real classroom and be able
to take advantage of a full educational
experience
healthcare staff in particular have been
pressing on for two years to care for
those with cobot and all other health
care concerns
they've provided an essential service
and we are grateful for their commitment
and sacrifices on behalf of their fellow
canadians
and to those who think that protesting
in front of hospitals is a good idea i
can assure you it isn't
the doctors and nurses working in those
hospitals are busy saving lives not
setting government policy
the last thing they should have to deal
with when coming off a long shift is the
site of angry placards or shouting
protesters
grocery store staff immediately come to
mind
as do all those involved in our supply
chain
including truckers
it may seem thankless to work in these
positions during a long a time like this
but i hope every single one of them
knows how critical they've been
it was on this understanding that
governments made a point of underscoring
which workers were essential at various
times throughout the pandemic
we all understand
that we owe a debt of gratitude to these
workers
we all want them
thank you
we all want them to know
how their contributions have helped all
of us through this time
and yet here we are today
after two years of truckers being deemed
essential workers the liberals decided
they no longer were
after two years of praising their
efforts doing what they do best
delivering the goods we rely on the
liberals decided trackers weren't really
essential after all
but the obvious question is
why
what changed mr speaker
i get the fact that many don't
understand why a certain percentage of
truckers don't want to get vaccinated
i get the argument that the vast
majority of other canadians have gotten
vaccinated so why wouldn't the others
regardless of your frustration with
those who won't get vaccinated we all
must have compassion and try to
understand that no matter the mandate
imposed upon them they simply will not
at this stage of the pandemic we must
ask ourselves what reasonable benefit
could society and our economy attain
from the trucker mandate
the liberals have failed to give any
rationale whatsoever for the decision
and if they're holding on to data
include indicating that the truckers
have been responsible for covet
outbreaks they've never shared it with
canadians
this lack of transparency is unfortunate
canadians deserve to know whether the
mandate on truckers is justified they
deserve to know whether the benefit of
taking truckers off the road outweighs
the impact of our economy to our economy
worse yet this government either has no
framework for lifting mandates or if
they do
they sure have a funny way of
communicating it to the public
we can all appreciate that this
situation is fluid
but the government should be able to
explain what metrics it is using to
determine the scope and speed for
removing mandates
on what basis
is it making its decisions
there's nothing strange about canadians
wanting transparency
from their government
in fact
the government if the government
had or had pardon me if in fact had the
government been more open with us
with its federal response perhaps we
wouldn't have seen the same levels of
angst among canadians
perhaps we wouldn't have seen the same
levels of frustration from millions of
canadians who are eagerly awaiting an
end to lockdowns and restrictions
it should go without saying at this
point
but people are tired
people are frustrated
after two years of personal sacrifices
many are looking to this government to
explain the path
forward
but to date
it seems like they're waiting in vain
many canadian public health officials
are significantly signaling that they
want to make a shift in policy
vc's medical chief medical officer has
indicated their covet response to it is
transitioning to become quote much more
like how we manage influenza end quote
as she stated and i quote we cannot
eliminate all risk and i think that's
something we need to understand and
accept as this virus has changed and has
become part of what we will be living
with for years to come and quote
and reply to the last question that was
asked of my colleague ontario's chief
medical officer has also said something
similar
i absolutely think quote i absolutely
think we have to start to learn
to live with this virus and we've let
our lives be controlled for the past for
the last two years in a significant
amount of fear and quote that's from
ontario's chief medical officer mr
speaker
and canada's top doctor is noting the
need quote to be able to address the
oncoming presence of
covet 19 in a more sustainable way
end quote
looking around the world many countries
are removing restrictions or laying out
the framework to do so
in the united kingdom it's been
mentioned in the house many times today
vaccine passports have been dropped
sweden is removing entry restrictions
and domestic rules and denmark ended
their covert restrictions last week
a recent angus raid poll showed that a
majority of canadians quote
now say it is time to remove
restrictions and let canadians manage
their own level of risk end quote
if the prime minister disagrees with
most canadians
then it's incumbent upon him to explain
his rationale
i doubt the prime minister wants to
unfairly label millions of canadians as
quickly as he
labeled those who partook in the convoy
as it made its way through canada
protests are occurring in communities
across the country but none are more
pronounced than what we've seen outside
this very place
he's painting every protester with a
broad brush
name calling
dismissing even the most genuine
concerns about his government's actions
over the last two years
there were literally thousands of people
lined up on highways in support of the
convoys
the only message they're hearing from
this prime minister is that because
they're supporting the convoy they too
must be beyond
redemption
make no mistake i denounce any all
symbols of hate and have zero tolerance
for illegal behavior
anyone who participated in that manner
should be ashamed of themselves
moreover i think everyone outside should
immediately minimize their impact on
those who live downtown here in ottawa
but my message to both the government
and to the protesters is turn down the
rhetoric
turn down the heat
we must remember
we are all citizens
and remain so and will remain so after
this
we cannot continue to just talk past
each other
we will get nowhere if we continue this
the leader of the official opposition
has requested a meeting between the
prime minister and other party leaders
so we can come together
deeply a lot deep politicize the
response to the pandemic
and talk about where we go from here
canadians need leadership
they need to see a plan
they need hope
on this side of the house we're prepared
to work together to end this protest and
help families and communities return
to their normal lives
i hope all parties will join in this
effort
secretary of the government house leader
thank you very much uh madam speaker
madam speaker a little over an hour ago
uh one of this members conservative
colleagues uh the member from wellington
halton hills gave a very passionate
speech in this house and though i didn't
agree with everything he said he made it
very clear that this blockade that's
going on outside is illegal as a matter
of fact he posted that uh video of his
speech and on twitter he's already
received well over a thousand retweets
and likes of that now this is a very
different approach madam speaker to this
issue being taken by the member from
wellington halton hill than we've seen
from the vast majority of conservatives
i would like to ask this member how he
feels about what the member from
wellington halton hills
said about this blockade being illegal
does he agree that it's illegal
the honourable member for brandon serris
mr speaker
my people in in bran and service the
people of the fine constituents of bran
and service believe that these peaceful
protests are allowable but madam speaker
the
occupation of downtown ottawa has been
uh going on for some time and the reason
it has been let's face it is because the
prime minister won't go out and talk to
them
so if this member wants to bring up
questions about
uh who said what then all i'll say is
the prime minister it's in his hands our
house leader our pardon me our interim
leader today has um written a letter to
the prime minister and in the questions
here this evening when the right to the
prime minister asked them to come
together with all political party
leaders and find a common ground to uh
end
the situation that's taking place not
just here on parliament hill and in
ottawa but across canada
the member for mirabel
president
to represent
is
is
thank you very much to my colleague for
his question and uh and i agree with
them in regards to
um
that there needs to be a solution to
this protest uh that's been taking place
and i've been involved in many uh
debates in parliament hill and uh as a
lobbyist coming uh in my lifetime as a
farm leader to ottawa many times to make
my point but we made it and went home
the situation here is just exactly what
i said in the first paragraph of my
presentation tonight it's our rise with
heightened awareness of just how divided
canada canadians have become
and why is that madam speaker
it's because
this prime minister
decided to put mandates on truckers in
canada after they were deemed to be
essential for 22 months since the
beginning of covent
we have time for a brief question the
honorary member for edmonton griezbach
thank you very much madam speaker and i
really want to thank the honorable
member from brandon soros for his
delineation between the real issues that
are facing our country one is division
of course and we both i believe condemn
the hate speech and the hate symbolism
that has been flouted our nation's
capital and across the country on the
other hand the members talked about the
pandemic and the issues with the
pandemic and i'm so encouraged to hear
that the member is encouraging members
of his constituency to get vaccinated
but the question i have for the member
is considering my home province of
alberta we have some of the highest
numbers still of covet 19 and ic units
are still in
surge capacity wouldn't the member agree
that provinces have also a role to play
in making sure that we can handle the
pandemic but also bring forward a plan
like the member talks about freezing
restrictions but that time is it now
would the member agree
the owner member for brandon soros well
i think uh i appreciate the member very
much for his question uh madam speaker
but i think the latest news is that that
i've heard over the weekend is that
alberta has 91 vaccinations and 87
percent of their population is
vaccinated with two vaccines now so i
think he needs to catch up on the
reality that that's actually
uh at least tied or maybe ahead of the
rest of canada in regards to
vaccinations in alberta now um and so i
think that uh
the member has
maybe a little bit of catching up to do
but that's not the point here it's it's
the fact that we need to be able to make
sure
that goods and services are delivered
across this country and that the prime
minister has been dividing the country
resuming debate the owner member for
king's hands
thank you madam speaker it's an absolute
privilege to be able to rise virtually
of course to give remarks on an
emergency debate on a topic that i think
is of very importance
to our country indeed of course to the
people in ottawa uh particularly with
what we're seeing with the protest to
date uh i would be remiss if i don't
mention that i'll be splitting my time
today with my honorable colleague from
vaughn woodbridge uh madam speaker i had
the opportunity about a week ago to
present in this house for 10 minutes on
the reply to the speech from the throne
but i used it as an opportunity to see
and to articulate what i was seeing
vis-a-vis the protests in ottawa and of
course there's been seven days
transpired since then and so it's given
me an opportunity to refine my thoughts
on what we've seen
members in this house have talked about
of course mps the opportunity to engage
i have seen that i have had the
opportunity to walk through
engage with people on my way back and
forth to the hotel and i'll give my
opportunity to opine on what i've seen
um but let me just try to give a
synopsis madam speaker on what my
remarks detailed about a week ago i
explained to my colleagues that my
father was a truck driver too and that i
am certainly
one of the elements that i think is
extremely important and a silver lining
of the pandemic perhaps has been a
reflection and a recognition of the
important role that our essential
workers play uh sometimes who can be
unsung heroes uh in their own right and
so as i did a week ago i'll go on record
for thanking all those men and women
that get up and to be able to make a you
know very honest living being able to
serve uh in an invaluable way to society
and hopefully all canadians are able to
reflect uh on
what they're able to bring whether it be
truck drivers
nurses other professions that are on the
front lines of this pandemic they are
doing important work and deserve to be
recognized
i i reminded this host why some of the
provincial and territorial measures are
in place including the measures that the
government of canada has introduced and
although i would agree with my
colleagues that certainly yes we are all
tired and yes we want to be able to move
away from covet and i take notice that
other jurisdictions around the world are
moving in that direction the reality is
the reason we are moving in this
direction on some of the protocols we
have in place
is that a disproportionate amount of
unvaccinated canadians represent the icu
cases in canadian hospitals from
newfoundland and labrador to british
columbia
i gave the statistic and yes i take
notice madam speaker that it would shift
perhaps on a daily basis but last week
for example 44 of icu cases in nova
scotia were tied up with nine percent of
unvaccinated nova scotians uh and so
it becomes a debate and we've heard
members go through this in terms of
individual freedoms versus collective
freedoms and and you know i'll reference
members back to my speech a week ago of
that tension and frankly every
parliamentarian indeed every canadian is
going to have a different ideological
bend on where exactly that line should
be
i gave an example of mark clark a
dedicated volunteer in my community
indeed some members might have seen in
the host last week
that i gave an so31 unfortunately about
his passing
his surgery was delayed for three weeks
his open-heart surgery that he needed
because there was not enough beds in the
health care system in nova scotia to be
able to accommodate him
now we can certainly reflect back madam
speaker and talk about the challenges
that existed in the health care system
our government has provided supports
provincial and territorial governments
are working hard to make sure the system
frankly doesn't collapse it speaks to
some of the fragility that existed but
that is the situation we are in
that is why we're imposing these
measures as we try to reduce the spread
and to try to avoid situations like mark
clark
who aren't able to be able to access
those surgeries
and frankly
unfortunately have passed away as a
result now again there's a spectrum
there in terms of individual freedoms
and protection versus harm and what that
line should be every member in this host
is going to have a perspective on that
but the reality is that is something
that is driving decision making at this
point
madam speaker i also certainly
highlighted the fact that no canadian in
the country is being required to take
the vaccine
and again we can weigh whether or not
the consequences of that freedom of
choice to choose to vaccinate or to not
to choose to vaccinate and the
repercussions of such are fair and
equitable i think that is all fair game
in this house but the idea that
individuals don't have the freedom to
choose on whether or not they want a
vaccine
i think is a fallacy
and frankly uh i want to certainly mind
be mindful of
the importance of colleagues in this
house and the tone and the measures that
we set and we've heard this elsewhere
madam speaker
from other colleagues who have spoken on
this tonight about the importance of how
we bring down rhetoric i think all
parliamentarians in this house all 338
of us have a role elected colleagues in
other places of the country it's not
one individual it's not
one side of this house we all have a
role to play and i think it's important
to be mindful of that in the days ahead
but i want to go to the protest in
question because that is the nexus
that's what we're talking about here
today
and yes i take notice madam speaker that
perhaps there are very well intended
people in fact as i went through some of
the protests in the last week i i saw
individuals that would be reflected of
perhaps the people that might live in my
riding individuals that had certain
concerns and wanted to bring those
forward i also saw a much very sinister
crowd
we saw confederate flags we saw
swastikas
we've seen businesses windows shattered
individuals who are flying pride flags
in ottawa being terrorized uh
individuals being shoved to the ground
the instances i could go on and on and
on
speaker so while there may be
well-intended individuals and i trust
that there are
there is also individuals who want to do
much more harm not just perhaps to
parliamentarians or to individuals but
to canadian democracy calling for an
unrule you know overthrowing governments
uh suggesting that they can go to the
governor general to dissolve parliament
it isn't it is frankly insanity uh madam
speaker and if members can't call it for
what it is they need to be able to do so
and and it brings me to my point
that if you are someone who is
protesting here in ottawa or elsewhere
in the country and you fashion yourself
as a well-intended individual who wants
to
exercise your section uh to uh sub b of
the charter of rights and freedoms to
protest
uh fine
but recognize that your voice is being
drowned out right now by individuals who
are far more sinister who have far more
sinister views
and i think the point has been made as
other parliamentarians have said in this
house if you are one of the good ones
it's time to go home
it's time
to go back and let the people of ottawa
have their rights and freedoms back
their ability to go to work unhindered
their ability to go on with their lives
without fireworks and horns and the
whole circus that we've seen here in
ottawa
and i and again i have to be careful
with my own words madam speaker but i
hope you sense my passion if you're one
of the good ones and you're watching
this here today it's time to go home
because indeed you have members of
parliament that will stand in this house
as we've heard here tonight and we'll
continue to debate the issues that
matter to you in fact that's what we do
in a democracy we as members of
parliament bring information back from
constituents that we hear
and we bring that message and we debate
it on the floor of the house of commons
not by clogging up streets and and i i
want to take it to the wet soweton
protest that we've seen in 2020.
frankly there was conservative members
of this house madam speaker that uh were
you know rightfully calling that there
was needed to be an end to the blockade
that this was something that was
disrupting the economic uh prosperity of
the country people were uh you know
shutting down critical infrastructure
now i take notice there has been some
conservative members particularly in the
last few days start to make a breakaway
and talk about that
but i think on the whole if i could
madam speaker through you there has been
hypocrisy
by the conservative party of canada they
have not used that same language and
that same principle and i stand here as
a member of parliament saying that
regardless of how you view the issue
regardless of what your issue may be you
do not have the right to shut down
critical infrastructure in this country
do not have the right to
do what you're doing if you want to come
to parliament hill and protest that is
your right it's a constitutionally
protective one but to create the
disruption and harm that is going on
right now it is not right madam speaker
and indeed every single member of this
house should be calling for the same
thing for individuals to go home
i only have about one one more minute
madam speaker uh ten minutes does not
suffice on on a conversation such as
this
where do we go from here individuals
have suggested the prime minister
negotiates or comes out and talks who
who do you negotiate with
it's a mob rule right now who would you
actually turn you know to those members
who have suggested that here tonight who
would you turn the prime minister over
to actually speak to in that group
because it's not clear to me who the
leadership of this group is and even
those that are seemingly leading i think
have a much more sinister view
i think it's time as the ministers have
indicated for the police to use their
discretion to be able to make sure that
this protest is wound down that we can
carry on within the business of the
nation and that members of parliament
can articulate uh in this house and
debate what needs to be debated thank
you madam speaker
questions and comments y'all remember
for sure with park for saskatchewan
thank you madam speaker i would put it
to the member that it's not about
negotiating it's about listening it's
about listening to the fact that there
are tens of thousands of people across
the country who are protesting in
different ways some of whom are driving
their trucks places and then going home
some of whom are staying place but the
point is people are concerned about
losing their jobs over mandates mandates
that need to end but i want to put a
specific question to the member and this
is about the discussion around foreign
funding because many members have raised
this issue oh for foreign foreigners are
donating money to this rally well
conservatives have been talking for a
very long time about the need for tough
new laws to address foreign interference
and address foreign funding and that's
constantly dismissed by the other
parties when it comes to all kinds of
other causes including election
interference so i'd like to ask the
member will his government put forward
legislation to address concerns about
foreign interference in our democracy
across the board you can't just complain
about it in one case and then let it go
in other cases but if the government is
going to put forward good faith
legislation that addresses foreign
foreign dollars coming into canadian
political debates across the board i
think there'd be a lot of support for
that in the house would the member put
forward that legislation
the owner member for king sands
thank you madam speaker i'd like to
address my colleagues first point around
individuals who are choosing to exercise
and and protest i have no issue with
individuals who want to protest i have
issue with people that are blockading
highways in alberta i have issue with
people that are blockading the downtown
of ottawa if the member suggests that
government should acquiesce to
individuals who protest yes i understand
governments need to listen governments
need to take into account that does not
always mean that they have to agree so
if the member opposite thinks that
government should just acquiesce and do
what individuals are driving and
suggesting is wrong and that's the way
we should run our democracy in this
country that is a very very poor view as
it relates to the the aspect around
financing yeah absolutely would agree
that if we are gonna move on a law to
have foreign interference it should
apply to all individuals through all
causes if that is the true desire where
government and parliamentarians want to
go
[Music]
it is
i don't think the protesters are just
gonna say okay let's go home they're
nervous i think the federal government
should have given you a question
message
from the very beginning
of the protesters
cooperated with the government of
ontario the city of ottawa and have a
plan from the beginning because now
things have gone too far
and we don't know what to do to get out
of it now
does the member propose what should the
government do to put an end to it
remember for king's hands
for her questions
um
[Music]
is
thank you madam speaker and i just
wanted to speak to a point that uh the
member from burnaby south brought at the
beginning of this debate and that is the
emergency rescue for the health care
system so i asked the member
of our our for about our health care
system will the member agree that it
starts with funding it properly and will
the government answer the calls of the
premiers to increase health care
transfers to the provinces
answer from the member for king's hands
thank you madam speaker i'll try in 30
seconds look i i think that there's
important investments that need to be
made in our health care system i don't
know if i necessarily agree with the
fact that they should be transfers
without strings from the government of
canada to ensure that outcomes are being
uh made
i don't speak for the government of
canada i'm a member of parliament that
happens to be in the governing caucus
i'll let our cabinet speak on that issue
but what i would say is i do think
there's opportunities for the ability
for private delivery still under a
single-payer model still under the
public model to deliver outcomes and
it's not all just about money it's about
how we can have better management and
healthcare system as well
resuming debate the honorary member for
von woodbridge
uh thank you madam speaker and and uh
good evening to all my colleagues uh
both here uh in presence and virtually i
hope everyone is doing well uh madam
speaker before i begin my formal remarks
um
uh before i begin my formal remarks
excuse me madam speaker
uh
i'd like to comment on the way i look at
the situation we are faced here with in
this wonderful blessed country that we
all call home and we as 338
parliamentarians have the privilege to
serve each of those residents that uh
that live in our ridings uh and come
here and do our best and put forward
what i would call reasonable leadership
reasonable leadership to debate the
issues reasonable leaderships uh to do
what is right for our constituents uh to
do what it's right and recommend for
their public safety for their public
health and do it as right to exit this
pandemic so we can all return uh to what
i would call a new normal but a normal
that we would want to see
we're in winter now
summer spring and summer will then come
and the days are getting longer and
hopefully soon it'll be getting warmer
and we'll want to be at a barbecue with
our friends traveling enjoying all of
what canada has to offer and we can do
that in a number of ways and for the
last two years canadians including those
wonderful residents of my riding of
baltimore bridge have been resilient but
they're tired we're all sort of tired
we're all tired of covet 19. we're all
tired of talking about it so when i
think about the best way to exit this
pandemic it's through vaccinations it's
through canadians doing the right thing
and they have
and they are
and we ask them to continue to do that
but we are seeing light at the end of
the tunnel we are but we have to be
patient
now that's the one aspect of what
canadians going through they're getting
back to work kids are back in the
province of ontario back in school
physically universities are opening up
uh for in-person classes it's great to
see our manufacturing business continue
to run our frontline workers continue to
do the great job they do day in day out
and they have of my utmost respect
but at the same time we still have work
to do and we need to be remain focused
on the ball now we have this
occupation or and this protest that has
gone here uh in the city of ottawa the
home our nation's capital
and as i said last week
on
a panel with some of my colleagues it
needs to come to an end
it does need to come to an end
it is disruptive it is disrupting
people's lives
from earning a living
for all those businesses along sparks in
a downtown core it has made people feel
very unsafe
and it is not about a trucking mandate
95 percent of
truckers in canada are vaccinated the
same rule applies in the united states
going into the united states or coming
into canada people need to be vaccinated
so there's no disagreement there we know
vaccine saves lives for those people on
the other side of the other my
colleagues on their side say well
truckers are by themselves no truckers
go home to a family member and see their
friends and we need them to get
vaccinated
and they have overwhelming numbers but
there are people
uh canadians out here that i have the
utmost respect for canadian is a
canadian as a canadian
that will disagree with that they don't
want to be vaccinated they don't believe
in that collective responsibility
that we all need to have as a country as
citizens of this beautiful country we
have a collective responsibility to exit
covet 19. we need to work together and
canadians
in an overwhelming majority have
now in the province of ontario the
lockdowns which many of these folks
outside are protesting against are
provincial lockdowns provincial measures
which are now being lifted today i read
that in the city of toronto uh this
summer that luminato and i think it's
caribana will be in-person events so we
are returning to see seeing some norm
normalcy we are starting to get that
back but it's coming incrementally
these individuals outside and i walk
through like many of my colleagues have
and you know looked at some of the signs
and stuff it's a hodgepodge of a lot of
different
uh issues
they want to overthrow a democratically
elected government
would you sit down with somebody who
wants to overthrow a democratically
elected government is that who you're
supposed to speak to i don't think so
that's not reasonable leadership
it's not reasonably leadership at all
and for many of my qualities on the
opposite side and my own side i'm not a
partisan mp i want to debate the issues
i want to do what's right for the
residents of my riding to make sure we
have a prosperous future
we've recovered more than 100 of our
jobs our economy is bigger than it was
pandemic we've done the right things
we've shown reasonable leadership and we
continue to show reasonable leadership
canadians don't expect perfection from
all 338 mps they expect us to do our
best
they expect us to do what is right
meeting with protesters who want to
overthrow a democratically elected
government is not what is right
and i know many of
the opposition members in the in
in the loyal opposition agree with that
and many have commented on their twitter
and social media platforms that the
occupation must end
if they people want to protest up and
down the sidewalks and hold placards and
hand out information pathways god bless
them
that is their right that is their sacred
right and i believe in civil liberties
but i also believe very much in
collective responsibility of doing
what's right for your neighbor
just like canadians in overwhelming
majority across this country in every
province in every city
rural urban have done
34 000 canadians have died because of
covet
the government has had the backs of
canadians for two years invested 500
billion dollars to support canadian
businesses families workers
by rapid tests
secure vaccines
the conservatives at one time said we'll
never get vaccines till 2030 or 25 or
28. well no they're here they're in
abundance and we're actually helping out
the rest of the world now
and that's what canada is about
so when i think of these the protesters
i have the utmost respect for them
they need to go home they need to bring
this to an end
the citizens of ottawa deserve that
respect
they deserve to have their lives back
the shopkeepers who invest their heart
and soul in their businesses that are
shut down deserve that
there's no one to talk to because
that's just not the right thing to do
please and simple
so
madam speaker when i think about
reasonable leadership
i say this blockades must end
because that's reasonable leadership we
must do what continues to do what's
right and i agree we need to continue to
i believe in science
absolutely i think every 338 mps who
believe in science i have faith
in what they say
they may not be perfect
but if their comment says we need to
transition we transition
but let's do it prudently let's do it
judiciously
let's do it in a safe manner that gets
us there let's not do what happened
happen in ontario where we open up fill
the stadiums full of people and then
we're going to shut down
because then
our hospitals are over capacity again
and then we have to cancel tens of
thousands of surgeries
and have people literally waiting months
and years to get surgery that they need
that is not responsible leadership
we as a government
are showing responsible leadership
and i plead to my colleagues i listen to
some of the debate earlier on
being respectful
is who we are as a people
not polite respectful
i.e we can debate we can scream
but we need to be respectful
and i hope to see that all the time
when i come into the house of commons
into this cradle of democracy if you
want to call it that into this house we
need to do that
but i'm a secret i did have some uh
formal notes and i'll read some of it
but what i really want to reiterate
tonight is these this occupation
these protests they need to come to an
end
this is not about trucking mandates
it's not about that
we need to exit cove at 19. that's our
focus
not anything else we need to keep
canadians safe
that's what we should all be doing
not meeting with protesters or who who
hold up awful placards
that we all know about and we don't need
to discuss again
who don't respect the rule of law
who don't respect the citizens of ottawa
to get a good night's sleep or for their
family to be safe and to feel safe
so madam speaker the protest against
vaccine manages is gripping the city of
ottawa as well as other parts of this
country
all members know
that covet 19 pandemic has cost us
dearly
with the loss of lice and livelihoods
not one of us has been untouched
it goes without saying that this period
has been long extremely challenging for
all canadians
the provinces and territories have
legislative authority to implement and
execute the pandemic response actions
that are appropriate for their
jurisdiction including implementing and
easing public health restrictions now
madam speaker i'll be the first one that
really wants to go to uh
a big wedding or my daughter's bapt
communion in a couple months so we can
fight all our relatives i see that
madonna speakers asking me to wrap it up
so i will stop there and just to say
it's nice to see everyone this evening i
hope you and your families are keeping
safe and i can't wait to see all my
colleagues in this place together
hopefully soon thank you madam speaker
and comments you don't remember for
brandon source thank you mr madam
speaker
um
i just want to uh thank my colleague for
his speech tonight and presentation but
he as well as his predecessor the speech
before him indicated that they didn't
know who they should go and talk to to
talk to the
to the to the trucking uh
organizations and individuals who are
out in the streets here and across
canada
but first of all you have to make the
offer
madam speaker we know that there are
organizers in this uh cavalcade they
didn't come all the way across canada
uh by just uh telephoning each other up
and saying we're gonna move across the
country and end up in ottawa uh there
are organizers
the government has failed to even ask
who that would be i'm sure if they put
an olive branch out to those people
they'd get a meeting in an hour
and our leader today our interim leader
has indicated that to the prime minister
that he should sit he should do that and
he should sit down with all of the
elected leaders of the parties in this
house and come up with a common solution
to end this uh blockade
the honor member for vaughn woodbridge
madam speaker i thank the honorable
member from brandon sirs for his for his
uh question what i will say is this you
know our government put in place a
measure to help protect canadians and
canadian in this place in this instance
truckers i spoke with a uh president of
a trucking company in the region i
represent 1300 employees uh 3 000 uh
beds if you want to call them that um
trailers excuse me and 95
of his workers 95 of his truckers were
vaccinated he operates in york region
and in the midwest and chicago and he
said to me francesco it is the right
thing to do and all my call and all my
employees who cross that border are
vaccinated
that is what i believe in when i talk to
the industry we gave the industry a long
runway to prepare for this measure
the canadian trucking alliance we spoke
with them they support us and they
support this stance that is what we need
to do
thank you speaker
questions and comments
from mirabelle
leadership
this government
please explain
thank you very much madam speaker
very important for us we have shown
leadership in working with the ottawa
police services in the city of ottawa in
collaborating with them and sending them
resources uh from the beginning of the
of the convoy uh until up to date we
have shown leadership in providing the
resources that they require and again i
wish to reiterate how can you go and
negotiate with individuals who want to
democrat who want to overthrow the
democratically elected government that
canadians voted for
uh in the last election uh that to me is
a something preposterous prosperous
sorry uh and something that is wrong you
don't go and negotiate uh with entities
that want everything for themselves and
have no need to no desire to cooperate
and in fact are not following public
health guidelines so we can finally exit
this pandemic
questions and comments a brief question
the member for nunavut
i wanted to thank the member for his
comments and uh
i just needed to express that i disagree
that
a canadian is a canadian is a canadian
the extremist activities have shown that
this is not the fact that this is not
the case
law enforcement has reacted very
differently to this extremist activities
compared to how law enforcement reacts
to first nations methi and in which who
have defended their lands
having said that i do want to ask the
minister
i'm sorry the member uh because he's
been talking about uh responsible
leadership does he not agree that it's
important that the prime minister meets
immediately with municipal municipal
leaders as a way to begin forward uh
towards uh ending the pandemic the enemy
sir the honourable member for vaughn
woodbridge um i thank the honorable
monroe colleague from none of it for her
question i will say that the lines of
communication between the federal
government and the city of ottawa and
the ottawa police services have been
constantly open they've been constantly
there we are collaborating we are
assisting them with resources from rcmp
officers to obviously intelligence
gathering anything they need we are
obviously there we don't direct the
police force without a police force to
do anything or undertake any sort of
activity uh they're independent uh and
there's a reason for that of course so i
would say to my honorable colleague we
are in constant contact with the city of
ottawa their mayor and the auto police
services for the resources they require
in this situation thank you madam
speaker
coming the bait the honorary member for
cumberland colchester
[Applause]
mr speaker i'm always honored to rise
here in the house i want to make it
clear i'm going to split my time with my
colleague from kamloops-thompson caribou
at the current time
the interim leader of canada's
opposition has reached out to canada's
prime minister to ensure a peaceful
and urgent end to a very guilt very
difficult situation and the question
that needs to be answered is will the
prime minister respond
what has become very clear in canada is
that the mood of canadians is moving
towards the beginning of the end of the
pandemic real life we realize that it is
not only the health of canadians
influenced by their physical health but
also by their financial
social and mental health
i can clearly recall in the early days
of the pandemic
holding the hand of someone about to die
from covet 19.
they were there without their family
their only way of communicating
with them was through an ipad
some small redemption
in those early days regarding this this
person was that i'd known them previous
previously
and they'd shared with me their journey
in life as a young person
how they documented a bicycle trip
across southern england
how they'd been essential to the
development of a hospital in cape breton
how their wife had died and how they
ended up living
in the small town of toronto nova scotia
indeed to watch this
90-something-year-old male die without
his family
will forever have a profound impact
on my view
of the covid19 pandemic
canadians have suffered
it's also important to reflect on the
grave concern we should all have now
have with respect to the mental health
of children and adolescents
indeed my own son is missed owed on his
high school graduation
and the wonderful social times that many
of us have experienced in the first two
years of university
getting your own place to live solving
your own problems
meeting new friends
and learning how generally to be an
adult all on your own have been things
that have been severely dampened by the
kovid 19 pandemic
this unfortunate part of the pandemic
and the associated isolation
is that many people live in their own
echo chamber
we've become isolated to the views of
the others who would often surround us
and engage us in exciting debate and
discourse
which sometimes of course led us to
agree to disagree
but other times led to truly led us to
truly engage in conversation which would
allow us to see another point of view
and perhaps indeed indeed change our own
point of view
another example of not seeing other
points of view is our inability to
travel
we need to better understand other
cultures
how they solve problems how they
communicate
and how they live
it's important that we do these things
this my friends and colleagues leaves us
with the need to question those things
important to us and help us better
understand how we need to help our
fellow human beings
as we have these multitude of different
experiences those things can help us
grow as individuals understand other
cultures learn new languages and be more
resilient to take on our everyday lives
that is not saying madam speaker that
travels an essential part of being a
canadian simply to say that there are
many things which can potentially make
us more tolerant of others
which we have deeply missed during this
pandemic
for many others it has led to the tragic
end of a business which they worked so
hard and spent their entire life savings
trying to build
the travel sector of course has been
particularly hard hit as has the
hospitality sector
restaurants are essential to our
communities and the socialization which
happens therein has suffered under this
unbearable yoke
we all know that canadians love to have
a beer or coffee and catch up with their
friends to see their expressions to
understand their burdens to help
shoulder the load and to share a great
laugh
sadly this too has been transformed by
covet 19
no customers
no socialization
and as i mentioned above living in your
own echo chamber
moreover canadians indeed
and indeed people around the world have
suffered with increased levels of
anxiety
they have lost trust they've lost hope
for the future and they've lost their
security
madam speaker what is hope
one might define it as the feeling of
expectation and desire for a certain
thing to happen
unfortunately there's been no certainty
and the ability to plan for the future
has been lost
we do know there are several things
which can benefit the health of our
human species
things such as good sleep
meaningful employment
doing something purely for the benefit
of another
important relationships and physical
activity
essential all of those have all of those
things have been disrupted by the kovid
pandemic
as we're all aware many if not if not
most of the provincial medical officers
of health are calling for the end of
mandates
countries such as the united kingdom
with 64 vaccination rates
in denmark with 80
vaccination rates
compared to the over 86 percent that we
have here in canada are removing
mandates from for masks and vas vaccines
and passports
we need to begin to recognize the time
to move forward is now
the canadians cannot be expected to live
their lives in this perpetual state of
uncertainty
and without hope as we go forward
to be very blunt there are many out
there who do not have many years left
i'm a 53 year old man
realistically i may have perhaps 15
vigorous years left
prior to the pandemic it would have been
17.
do i want to continue my life not seeing
the joy of smiles on faces
not being able to travel
not being able to have social events
with constituents limiting my gatherings
with family on special occasions such as
christmas and thanksgiving
to have birthdays that are drive-bys
with horns honking from neighbors with
signs on our lawns
this my friends and colleagues it's not
living
it is also very clear from recent
studies that lockdowns are not are not
effective
we now know how much the poor federal
health care funding in canada and the
lack of surge capacity has perpetuated
this pandemic
prior to the pandemic in my small town
with a hundred beds in our hospital we
were perpetually worked between 90 and
130 percent capacity
our intensive care beds in canada per
hundred thousand people are half of
those available in the united states and
one third available of those in germany
now sadly we have an unimaginable
tsunami in terms of the backlog of cases
of diagnostic imaging of laboratory of
special appoints specialist appointments
and mistreatments
how is this perpetual underfunding ever
going to allow this catch-up to happen
with an overburdened infrastructure and
a tired exhausted
burned out human health resources of
physicians nurses and other allied
health care providers
so madam speaker how does this all end
do we simply trudge forward one foot in
front of the next without any hope or
indeed is this a defining moment in
humanity where those around the globe
begin to realize that unfortunately
sometimes
and sadly there can be a face fate worth
worse than death
how do we begin to move forward
one great way is to look at the
legendary colin powell's legacy of the
13 rules of leadership
general powell was arguably one of the
most influential writers on leadership
in the western world in modern times
as he would suggest number one it ain't
as bad as you think it will look better
in the morning
number two get mad then get over it
number three avoid having your ego so
close to your position that when your
position falls your ego goes with it
number four it can be done
five be careful what you choose you may
get it six don't let adverse facts stand
in the way of a good decision
seven you can't make someone else's
choices you shouldn't let someone else
make yours
eight check small things nine share
credit ten remain calm and be kind
11. have a vision be demanding
12. don't take counsel of your fears or
naysayers
and 13 perpetual optimism is a force
multiplier
all these rules of leadership are not
perfect leadership is not perfect
one of these things that we also must
know about great leaders that you must
try
you must care
in the immortal words of john f kennedy
we do not do these things because they
are easy because they are hard
i implore this prime minister to check
the ego
check the position and meet with leaders
of the other parties and bring this
situation to a peaceful and urgent end
thank you madam speaker
questions and comments
don't um
like to thank the member from cumberland
colchester for
his uh comments and and also i want to
extend my um my condolences for the
passing of your friend
um and and i appreciate uh a lot of what
you said um i'd like to just hear from
you uh in particular around since we're
talking about um the protest the convoy
in front of the hill right now and and
you didn't mention this at all in your
address and i'm curious about your um
your opinions and your um your thoughts
on this but but we see
for example swastikas we see um
hate speech we see
uh illegal acts such as arson you didn't
have any comments on this i'm curious
what are your thoughts on these on these
acts on these
flags etc
remember
to ensure that he addresses all
questions and comments through the chair
and not to the member directly the
honorable cumberland colchester
speaker thanks very much i'll uh
i will thank the member for his question
you know
my speech tonight madam speaker was the
attempt to turn the temperature down
here this is a very very volatile and
unfortunate situation uh you know i i
think it's really important that we
understand that
members on both sides of this house have
continued to
say that those acts are deplorable the
despicable and i think that
i find it unfortunate if
my my colleague opposite wants to
continue to perpetuate that that is
something that anybody in this house
would stand for i think that's very very
unfortunate it's inflammatory and it's
the exact those exact reasons that i
chose in my speech not to talk about
those things but to realize madam
speaker that we need to begin to get to
the end of this situation that's very
very volatile thank you madam speaker
thank you madam speaker i'd like to
thank my colleague for his speech i uh
enjoyed listening to it and
it's true that
people have developed
anxiety and they've become cynical and
many have lost their trust
in our institutions and all because as
you said
[Music]
and i think it's unfortunate that the
government hasn't followed those rules
a good idea that the leaders of the main
parties get together to find solutions
to the crisis but does he not think that
it would be even more productive for the
federal government to meet with the city
of ottawa the ottawa police service and
the government of ontario and all the
different groups who are on the ground
to find a solution to this crisis thank
you i remember cumberland told chester
president
[Music]
i think it's time for a direction for
the plan for the
future of uh occupation
of our country canada thank you
member for edmonton strathcona
thank you madam speaker and i want to
start by acknowledging what the member
said in this in his intervention that
you know people are suffering that
covenanting has been terrible that
people have died people have lost so
much that it has been very difficult but
you know he talks today he talked to my
colleague from the other party about
turning the temperature down you know
last week i had to ask my staff person
not to come to work she is a young
muslim woman and i was afraid for her
safety i have another colleague working
in my office that that is taking a sick
day because she has not been able to
sleep and she's deeply traumatized so
how can members of the conservative
party of canada continue to create a
public relations campaign out of the
occupation international's capital um
you know by posing with protesters
posting messages to support and fueling
further divisions with their own party
and across this nation
cumberland colchester brief answer
please madam speaker that is exactly the
thing that we're trying to avoid here
this evening we think it's very very
important even with respect to the
audacity of members opposite that we
need to turn the temperature down we
need to get the the uh the occupation
finished and be able to move forward and
and get back to the great things that we
have to offer here in canada thank you
madam speaker
thank you and i do want to remind
members that when someone has the floor
to please be respectful um and there's
opportunities ask questions and comments
at the proper time uh resuming debate
beyond member for kamloops thompson
caribbean
[Applause]
uh thank you madam speaker always a
pleasure to rise on behalf of the
residents and people of kamloops
thompson caribou especially on an
important topic like this one
let me be direct madam speaker
i would love to see an end to what is
going on
outside
a peaceful end
and that end begins with the prime
minister
has been a difficult situation for
everybody
obviously everybody in this house
denounces any violence any racialized
gestures or symbols that have been
displayed
over the last
two weeks
i rose in this house seven days ago as a
shadow minister for veterans affairs to
raise that very point
when it came to the tomb of the unknown
soldier and i have no regrets
on that point
madam speaker covet has left us with a
very fluid situation
initially people were unsure whether or
not to wear a mask
then people donned masks at the requests
of government
then we waited for a vaccine then we got
a vaccine
then we got our second dose of the
vaccine and then we got our boosters and
i personally did all of these things as
quickly as possible and i encourage
those around me to consider doing the
same your hair
canadians have been asked to give and
they have given a lot throughout this
pandemic
i myself was reflecting earlier today on
one of my young children who would not
remember a period pre-pandemic
the point is this madam speaker we all
want to get to normal the people outside
want to get back to normal
the people of ottawa living
and working in the surrounding area want
to get back to normal i want the people
outside to get back to normal i want the
people living and working in the
downtown area to get back to normal i
would love to see the people of kamloops
thompson caribou get back to normal and
i want to see all canadians
get
back to
normal one thing that we've repeatedly
heard madam speaker is the prime
minister say
we have your backs
i prefer to take a different approach
though
it's canadians who've had one another's
backs the doctors who've had our backs
the grocery store workers keeping
groceries available for us the
pharmacists filling our prescriptions
the respiratory therapists helping us
nurses doctors
truckers
these are the people who've had one
another's backs and i'm thankful to live
in a country like canada
where we can make that claim
in my view madam speaker a prime
minister is a prime minister to all or
is a prime minister to none and there is
no middle ground
as my honorable colleague from none of
it just mentioned when
addressing my colleague from vaughn
woodbridge
she referenced to the term a canadian is
a canadian is a canadian which in my
recollection was a reference
to when the prime minister opposed
stripping citizenship for people
committed
of terroristic of terrorism offenses
we should not forget that the prime
minister knelt
with protesters within the last two
years in breach of covet protocols
and yet
here we have a prime minister that is
dividing canadians
madam speaker
i have great trouble when i hear the
prime minister blame
unvaccinated people calling them names
adjectives like fringe
racist misogynist
from the most basic level madam speaker
if one wants to encourage another
to do something like get vaccinated
the best way to do it isn't to call them
a name
it's to encourage them to answer the
question if anything
those types of divisive tactics will
alienate
rather than
resonate with people who are
unvaccinated
at the most basic level madam speaker
the prime minister's job
is to unite as is everybody's job in
this house
unfortunately i'm seeing a prime
minister who is choosing to divide
which is genuinely unfortunate
in my capacity as member parliament for
kamloops thompson caribou i've had many
discussions with people both vaccinated
and unvaccinated
the prime minister may not
appreciate this
but i've had reasonable discussions with
people on all sides of the debate
some people i would call hesitant and
they have questions
that's why i share with them my
experience tell them what i've done why
i did it
and i invite and encourage them to do
the same
but i can't force i can't compel
a health care decision
which leads me to the point
of leadership and how we go
from today monday
to tomorrow tuesday madam speaker
this today tomorrow is the time to
resolve what is happening
outside
i walked around today to and from
parliament hill two or three times
i probably heard one or two horns all
day which for those who've been here for
the past couple of weeks is kind of is
anomalous and i
that's likely due to the recent civil
injunction
but i noticed something the tone felt
different
it was quieter
now is the time for a peaceful end madam
speaker
we don't have 5 000 people outside we
have
a few hundred people remaining
madam speaker if i could speak to the
prime minister through you
this
is what i would say
i would tell the prime minister that
today he brought his partisan hat to the
chamber and that tomorrow he should take
that partisan hat off
i would say today the prime minister
took an us versus them approach and that
tomorrow he should meet with the leader
of the opposition the leader of the
black quebecois and the leader of the
new democratic party who arranged and
requested this emergency debate
that today
the prime minister's approach was to
look at other people as different
but tomorrow i encourage him to see all
canadians and their desires to move on
from the current impasse
the past two years madam speaker have
been hard
enough difficult enough
so i would say to him through you madam
speaker please be a prime minister to
all and help end this impasse thank you
uh questions and comments the member for
mississauga erin mills
thank you very much madam speaker and i
thank the member for his uh for his very
passionate speech the members said uh in
his speech that the prime minister's job
is to unite as is everyone's in this
place
now over the past two years we've seen
34 000 canadians have died from kobe 5
million across the world
people in ottawa have had to file
injunctions as the members said himself
in order to get a little bit of peace
and quiet
so
when we see uh you know members from the
opposite side going in and joining uh
this occupation of ottawa disturbing the
residents and and the peace of ottawa
does does the member not think that he
himself has a responsibility to do the
right thing to be democratic to stand up
for the values of democracy of our great
nation
i'll remember for kamloops johnson
caribou
madam speaker i feel that's what i'm
doing right now
discussing all canadians not just some
canadians i implore a peaceful
resolution to what's happening right now
but when we talk about democracy in a
peaceful resolution
we're about two weeks in now
where has the prime minister been the
last two weeks madam speaker
that's really the big question
but let's not focus just on where he's
been the last two weeks let's focus on
where he's going to be the next day and
the next day after that in bringing a
resolution to what's happening
is
um
madam speaker and i i thank my uh
honorable colleague
for his uh his helpful remarks and for
his comments
madam speaker at this point
i feel a lot of what we can do has
really been exhausted
if i can put it bluntly the ball is in
the prime minister's court
he is the
he is the head of state of canada
and i endorse what the leader of the
opposition has suggested which is a
meeting between himself
the leader of the opposition the leader
of the bloc and the leader of the ndp
these are the leaders of the four
official parties in the house of common
who better than to hit the ground
running to put a peaceful end to listen
to the people who are outside and to
hopefully move forward in all facets
that are necessary thank you
have time for a brief question the honor
for edmonton strathcona
thank you madam speaker and i would like
to thank my colleague you know others
have said today and and i will say that
as well my father was a trucker my dad
duke mcpherson was a trucker he's
worried about truckers i'm worried about
truckers uh so so what i want to know
from this member you know when you talk
about doing the right thing listening
helping out
why is it that the conservative party if
they really wanted to help truckers why
do they reliably vote against improving
safety regulations and enforcement about
vote against better working conditions
vote against increased ability and
support for unionizations vote against
improving workers rights you know that's
their legacy in this house of commons if
they actually want to support truckers
why do they constantly vote against
trucker's best interest
uh a brief uh response to the remember
kevin love stones and caribou i think my
honorable colleague for her question
obviously i'm not sure what particular
legislation she's referring to so it's
very difficult for me to answer a
question about the general legislation
as conservatives and as all people in
this house we want what's best for
canadians and i am prepared to fight for
that as are all conservatives thank you
very much
[Applause]
resuming debate the owner of
parliamentary secretary to the minister
to the minister of international
development
thank you very much madam speaker and
i'd like to share my time with the
member for mount royal
madam speaker
i never thought that i would be in this
house having a debate an emergency
debate like this with our city ottawa
under siege in a state of emergency
we've heard so much today from many
members in particular the honorable
member for ottawa center and my good
friend
who talked about
what is happening just meters away from
the house of commons what is happening
to the citizens the the dev the
desecration of our national monuments
including the national war memorial
of what is happening with the noise the
incessant noise how it's impacting
children children with autism people
with dementia people who have to live in
the residential districts around
downtown
we have heard about the treatment the
assaults the verbal assaults the threats
the way in which people wearing masks
are being treated the people who are
working downtown
we have heard that all evening
i'd like to talk a little bit today
about the impact on my constituents my
riding is only 15 minutes from downtown
and most of my constituents many of them
work downtown
many of them have not been able to go to
work whether it's on bank street or at
the rito center they haven't been able
to collect a paycheck for the last 10
days
and those who have had the opportunity
to go to work are terrified they're
being threatened they're being harassed
i had a man write to me to tell me that
he works at a church a church and this
weekend
while at work inside a church he had to
call the police because he was that
threatened
i have mothers whose daughters live
downtown who have said that their
daughters and their friends are facing
threats of murder threats of sexual
assault this is not something that we
should be living in the capital city of
our country
i was heartbroken when i heard from
jewish mothers in my writing who are
saying
how do i explain to my children
the people are wearing the yellow star
that people are flying the swastika
what do i say to my children
and this is at a moment where in one of
the neighborhoods in my riding where we
have a large jewish population there
were trucks driving around with vile
symbols
this is what's happening in our city
right now
we had a mother with autism when they
were going down carling avenue for hours
honking their horns who a
mother whose child has autism who
actually said she was taking him to the
emergency because there was no other way
to get away from it
so yes it is having an impact
and i have a coffee hour with my
constituents every friday it's virtual
now
and there's a young man a young
racialized man
who
said to me i don't understand it's
almost a loss of innocence how can it be
that he can't go downtown in his own
city because of the color of his skin
and what was really important about that
coffee hour is that people in that
coffee hour we're listening to each
other we actually had some people who
were at the protests attend the coffee
hour and hear the impact that it is
having on some of the racialized lgbt
and other members of our society and i
think that
people need to to listen to one another
more and be decent again because what's
happening out there right now that is
not decent it is not peaceful when
you're threatening violence that is not
peaceful
and the impact goes even beyond what's
happening downtown the queensway carlton
hospital in my riding has not been able
to get their workers from gatineau on
the other side of the bridge to be able
to come to work the nurses and the
frontline healthcare workers so people
in my constituency are not able to get
the help when they're sick and worse yet
the chio the children's hospital is
having trouble
this is the impact that it's having this
is not about political speech anymore
maybe it started to be about that but
now it is about mob rule it's about
intimidation it's about bullying and it
has absolutely no place in our city or
in our country so anybody that is saying
that this is a peaceful protester it's
somehow about expressing political
opinions that's not what it is and i
think anybody now having seen the impact
on people how this is hurting people it
is unleashing hate
anybody who sees that impact
should not be out there posing for
pictures or giving coffee
madam speaker
i've worked in parts of the world
where politicians thought that they
could draw that line that they could toy
with these forces of hatred and somehow
use them for political gain
and we've seen what happened i've worked
in sarajevo i have worked in kosovo i've
worked in the congo you can't put those
forces back in
you have to denounce them you have to
denounce them every single time you
cannot stop those forces once you
unleash them you cannot control them
anymore
and mr speaker madam speaker
when people say why are we not talking
to them
well i don't think that we want to tell
other canadians that if they were to
come with with large trucks with lots of
noise and threaten people and and cause
the kind of terror that they've caused
to people in ottawa center they're
they're they're scaring people that if
you do that
that's how you can be rewarded by being
heard being listened to and and who are
them i i'd like to think about they're
not the truckers because 90 of the
truckers are vaccinated and and most of
the truckers are out there doing their
job and they're not even anymore the
people who like all of us we are all
tired of covid we're all tired of of the
measures and and the lockdowns but it's
not even about that anymore there are
people who are a few feet from our house
of commons who are calling for the
overthrow of our government who are
calling for harm to come to members of
parliament that is an attack on the
institutions of our democracy and they
want people to lose faith in our
institutions
and that is something that we absolutely
cannot condone
madam speaker people have asked what are
we doing about it every single request
from the city of ottawa
what the federal government has provided
we have 300 rcmp officers we have
tactical and logistical support we have
joint intelligence and operations teams
community liaison teams and we're
coordinating between all levels of law
enforcement the politicians do not
direct the police i personally this
weekend and and before this i've been
talking to other levels of government
i've been communicating with the mayor
with the provincial mpp the prime
minister has been doing that the public
safety minister from the beginning and
we've also talked amongst
parliamentarians about solutions to this
that maybe we need to be looking at the
financing of these movements we need to
ban symbols like the swastika and the
confederate flag and i would say the
member from hall elmer
articulated perfectly the impact that
that has on black canadians we need to
look at social media and how it
propagates hate speech we need to
support the businesses and the workers
who haven't been able to go to work this
week
but madam speaker
as i as i finalize my words
i want to leave with one
thing
most people are good
canadians aren't as divided as people
think they are the fact is 90 of
canadians are wearing masks and getting
vaccinated and making sure that they're
protecting their neighbors in fact what
we've seen this week the shepherds of
good hope the homeless shelter where
where people were were trying to get
food and some of the women's shelters
are getting more donations than they've
ever gotten the legion the terry fox
foundation we have people who live in
the neighborhood around the hospital who
are saying that those workers who can't
get home and back safely can stay in
their spare room we have truckers that
continue to go out there and deliver
goods
and these are the good people these are
the decent good people and i think we
need to as we're living through all of
this and seeing all of this and it it
starts to affect you and make you wonder
about humanity we need to see that the
vast majority of canadians are good so
i'll leave with one quote from the
doctors and nurses in ottawa they wrote
a statement and what they said
was
we will not cower
we will not hide
we will wear our scrubs in public
without fear
knowing that you canadians have our
backs and that is exactly what we have
thank you madam speaker
questions and comments questions
the honourable member for report
moderate
thank you madam speaker and i just
wanted to thank the member for the
comments today and to thank you for
shining a light on the voices that have
not yet been heard tonight
uh you know who else hasn't been heard
madam speaker it is the nurses the
nurses and the care workers the member
just spoke of that are working in the
hospitals tonight caring for people i
raise my hands to the health care
workers and to the nurses experience
violence on their way to work i see you
and i offer all of my gratitude to you
from myself and the people of port moody
coquitlam
the i remember the honor parliamentary
secretary
i really want to thank my honorable
colleague for raising that and i think
we all share that same sentiment
those nurses those doctors those
front-line health care workers are there
every single day caring for us whether
we take their medical advice or not
about getting vaccinated they are they
are there they are going to work and
they say they're not heroes but we know
that these are the people that we need
to be supporting these are the people
and this is why we've made it illegal
that they that anybody would would
harass a health care worker on their way
into a hospital and that is happening
right now in ottawa and i want to
applaud along with all members here the
courage and the incredible sacrifice of
those workers thank you questions
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
oh
is
thank you madam speaker and i i would
say that in fact uh we just today
announced that we're going to have a
trilateral meeting between the different
levels of government
we know that people don't want to hear
us say oh it's about jurisdiction but
the fact is that
politicians do not direct the police and
what we need to be doing as politicians
is as as a federal government provide
all the resources so that the police who
have jurisdiction have everything that
they need to be able to uphold the law
to be able to do their jobs and madam
speaker i would say that we have been
from the very start in fact from before
the time that the the convoy reached
ottawa we have been having that
coordination we have been talking with
law enforcement and at every single
level political leaders have been
talking and as i mentioned i've been
talking with even in my constituency
when uh when they were rooting them
through a residential neighborhood in my
constituency i got talked to the mayor
and the provincial mpp to make sure that
the convoy wasn't being welcomed and
sent down woodruff avenue um that every
single day these conversations are
happening and they've been happening
from
the municipal councillors right up to
the prime minister and we need to keep
doing that and then after this is over i
do believe we will have lessons to learn
we will need to sit back and wonder and
and i think in fact in part we want to
allow for one quick question before i
was trying to give the honourable member
uh a sign there to wrap it up uh a brief
a question the honorary member for
brandon sewers
thank you madam speaker and i just want
to ask my colleague why the prime
minister has put all of his eggs in one
basket will not go out and speak to the
truckers but the truckers have given
them an option
the associations that i've spoken to in
the trucking industry have said that if
they'd had a negative test available
they'd have taken a negative test and if
they proved that they were negative
they'd go to work
and if they were positive they would
isolate like anyone else i just wonder
if she could elaborate on
why we don't have enough we didn't have
enough uh
rapid test kits in canada from the
middle of december the middle of january
at least anyway so uh it couldn't be
done but
if they are available now as the prime
minister says
why wouldn't they allow that very brief
answer from the honorable prominent
secretary
thank you madam speaker and we've
actually procured just this month 140
million rapid tests but also these are
not the truckers the trucking
association signed a joint statement
with the minister saying that he's they
support the vaccine mandate 90 of
truckers are vaccinated that's not who's
out there on the lawn right now
resuming debate the honorable
parliamentary secretary to the minister
of public services and procurement
i want to start by saying how sorry i am
to the people of ottawa and the
businesses of ottawa for what they have
experienced over the last 10 days
nobody deserves to experience what they
have
there are those who say that this convoy
is about freedom
i certainly agree that after two years
of a pandemic most canadians yearn for
freedom but most canadians also agree
that freedom comes with obligations
and those obligations include protecting
the most vulnerable in our society this
means we all need to get vaccinated
because without getting vaccinated new
variants will continue to emerge and our
hospitals will be overburdened
this means we need to wear masks indoors
because we know that the virus spreads
more quickly in poorly ventilated or
crowded indoor settings so when someone
calls for all mandates to be terminated
they are going against science
but that does not mean that other
restrictions should not be constantly
reconsidered there are many in this
country who are double vaccinated and
boosted they have done everything right
over the last two years and believed
that they were seeing the light at the
end of the tunnel
then omicron hit us in december our
health care system that lacks adequate
surge capacity was about to be
overwhelmed and politicians had to act
these restrictions involved a travel
advisory and added testing upon return
at the federal level
but the vast majority of these
restrictions were imposed by provinces
including by conservative provincial
governments
everybody was trying to do their best
using their best judgment but that does
not mean that everyone agreed with the
decisions and they all merit debate
i can fully understand why parents are
confused and upset when their kids are
having their schools closed with the
kids mental health having been so deeply
impacted
i can understand why some business
owners can't understand why their
businesses are closed while other
comparable businesses are open
i have a friend who runs a gym i have a
friend who runs an adult basketball
league they have been constantly closed
of the last two years
given the importance of working out to
physical and mental health it is hard
for me to explain to them why this is
the case
believe me i get it
there needs to be reasonable
conversations about why vaccinated
people and business owners are subject
to restrictions and we need a plan that
provinces in the federal government
agree upon to talk about how other
restrictions will be relaxed but let me
be clear
these frustrated canadians are not
represented by the protests currently
going on in ottawa and other cities
demonstrations are important expressions
where citizens make their views known
they typically involve
local residents receiving a municipal
permit making their case and then
leaving after a reasonable period of
time
they involve a careful choice of
location and normally organ organizers
go out of their way to not disrupt the
lives of people and businesses this is a
constitutionally protected right that we
need to respect whether or not we agree
with the cause
but while legal peaceful assembly is a
constitutionally protected right the
blockade of a city is not
the rule of law still exists in canada
honking all night long and keeping
people awake sending off fireworks
and refusing to follow local rules
related to wearing masks in indoor
settings are not part of a normal
peaceful protest
harassing citizens and journalists is
not part of a normal peaceful protest
desecrating monuments is not part of a
normal peaceful protest targeting health
care workers is not part of a normal
peaceful protest stealing from food
banks is not part of a normal peaceful
protest
and let me say loudly and clearly that
flying confederate flags is not part of
a normal peaceful protest
waving swastikas
and wearing yellow stars and having the
nerve to compare your situation to jews
who are murdered in the holocaust
is not part of a normal peaceful protest
my colleague from holly elmer spoke
beautifully
about what it meant to him as a black
canadian to see people waving the
confederate flag
let me just say that as a proud jewish
canadian seeing some fellow canadians
waving flags with nazi symbols and
wearing and selling the stars of david
the jews were forced to wear to separate
them from the rest of the society in
nazi era
made me more sad and angry than i have
ever been as a parliamentarian
i have heard from constituents of mine
who are holocaust survivors and the pain
and anguish that this has caused them
cannot even be described in words
what kind of people would do this
well mr speaker the organizers madam
speaker the organizers of the convoy
have made clear what their goal is their
goal is the removal of the duly elected
government their goal is the abolition
of all mandates and restrictions whether
scientifically validated or not
the convoy has some organizers who have
white nationalist and bigoted social
media histories and who is supporting
the convoy mr speaker madam speaker
well it is supported by donald trump and
ron desantis and ted cruz and matt gates
and paul gosore and marjorie taylor
green
i think my colleagues know that i
believe we can disagree without
personalizing things
but these politicians are different
because they are actually attacking
american democracy
the hallmark of democracy is that the
loser concedes an election
but in this case these politicians have
propagated the false and laughable claim
that donald trump won the 2020 election
even though these claims were laughed
out of almost every court two weeks they
were brought
indeed trump's lawyer rudy giuliani had
his law license suspended for
communicating demonstrably false
comments
to courts in his capacity as trump's
lawyer
i personally have no issue with
americans commenting on canadian
politics in the same way that i reserve
my right to complain about laws in u.s
states than make it more difficult for
minorities to vote and stop women from
having safe and accessible abortions
but what we do not need is further
disinformation in canada
people already have enough
disinformation about vaccines the last
thing they need is disinformation about
our democracy and the presence of trump
2024 signs of this blockade is a deep
concern
so what do we need to happen
people are frustrated in one action
i want to thank the men and women of the
ottawa police and the parliamentary
protective services as well as the opp
and rcmp and other forces who have done
their best
but even though this is under the
jurisdiction of the city of ottawa
nobody wants to hear about jurisdiction
we have a huge problem citizens lives
are being disrupted they do not want to
hear excuses from others that this is
not their jurisdiction they want all
governments to work together to have
this convoy leave ottawa they want a
safe and peaceful and respectful end to
this blockade
i was very pleased to hear the
announcement today that all levels of
government will work together
may i suggest they also need to
communicate together
all of us need to see a daily press
conference with all three levels of
government and the operational leaders
at the police level so that canadians
know exactly what is being done to
protect the rule of law and re-establish
order in the city we need to solve this
issue and end these blockades but once
that is accomplished what do we need to
do
we need to have a parliamentary
committee study exactly what happened
with this convoy
how did a convoy end up being allowed to
park trucks across from parliament hill
what security changes are needed what
legislative changes are needed to ensure
that local police forces can request
federal assistance more easily
should there be federal responsibility
for policing in downtown ottawa that
currently does not exist
we need to understand how this convoy
was financed and whether or not there
are countries seeking to cause trouble
in canada by financing illegality
it is one thing to receive donations
from the united states
but if u.s donations can come in this
case it would be equally easy for our
adversaries like russia and china to
send funds what legislative changes if
any are required to protect our
democracy
and the member for new west minister
burnaby has brought forward a private
member's bill to make the use of racist
symbols and emblems such as the swastika
and confederate flag criminal subject to
carve outs i think this is indeed a
subject we need to quickly tackle
while this has been a very unhappy
experience madam speaker let's learn
from what happened and use the
experience to ensure that this cannot
happen again and that we take steps to
enhance and protect our democracy thank
you madam speaker
questions and comments remember a member
for bruce greyer winston
thank you madam speaker i have just two
quick
questions for
my colleague for both from constituents
so one
from a female police officer in my
riding that got her first vaccine
unfortunately had an adverse reaction
and is scared and now she's mad at a
prime minister that's calling her
misogynist and racist
for having health concerns and the
second one from a fully vaccinated
health professional in my riding
who
is seeing other countries around the
world with less vaccination uptake that
are opening up and lowering their
federal
equivalent mandates and restrictions and
wants to know when is this federal
government going to lift the
restrictions here in canada
the honorable parliamentary secretary
thank you very much the first thing i
would say is that if somebody had an
adverse reaction to the vaccine there is
an exemption that they can then procure
to not be fully vaccinated i don't know
the situation exactly of your
constituent but if she truly had a
reaction a negative reaction to the
vaccine and her physician advised her
against it then she can procure an
exemption in most provinces
secondly i as i stated i believe that
vaccination vaccine mandates are
important i believe
that public health
rules like mask wearing indoors still
have to be followed but that doesn't
mean that we don't have to look at our
restrictions for vaccinated people
including for example whether or not we
still need a travel advisory whether or
not we need testing uh in addition to
the prc test pcr testing when you leave
your destination more testing when you
arrive all of these need to be
reconsidered in light of new facts and
you know we all need to do that at the
provincial and federal level
questions
foreign
perhaps you could give a very brief
foreign
i declare the motion carried accordingly
this house stands adjourned until later
this day at 10 a.m pursuant to standing
order 24 1.
good night everybody
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
foreign